♪ Just text your questions
and no stressing ♪
♪ 'Cause you're sipping tea ♪
♪ Team GaryVee ♪
- Good morning everybody.
It is Monday and it is "Tea With GaryVee".
I am your host, Gary Vaynerchuk.
I'm super excited to
be here with everybody
trying out a new platform.
Big, big shout out to StreamYard.
We'll see what that's about.
And I'm really, really
darn excited about this.
I hope you enjoy today's episode.
We got a bunch of great callers.
And I'm ready, ready, go.
So, Dustin, you can
throw 'em up, let's go.
- Hello.
- Hello, good morning.
How are you?
- I'm good, how are you?
- I'm super well.
- That's good.
First of all, thanks for the opportunity
to talk to me about this.
That's really cool.
- Of course, where are you
from? What's your name?
- My name is Janae.
I'm from Detroit.
- It's a real pleasure, Janae
- Thank you, it's a pleasure as well.
So, my question is kind
of a weird question
because I'm in a situation
that I didn't anticipate being in.
So, when I initially
started doing what I do,
I make YouTube videos
and Instagram videos,
they're usually comedy-related,
because I wanted attention on my writing.
- Okay.
- And people started to like
my acting, which is not a bad thing.
That's great.
- Yeah.
- But it takes away from the opportunity
to actually work on my writing,
because now people expect
videos like every fucking day,
and a script takes work every fucking day.
So now--
- So don't make the videos.
- That's that's where I'm at.
And I'm like, I feel bad
because I have people
that enjoy my stuff and I
don't want to let them down.
So, now I feel obligated to make some--
- But you're letting yourself down.
- Yeah (laughs).
Yeah, I am.
- Listen, people were devastated
when I stopped "Wine Library TV".
People said that I shouldn't
make business videos,
I shouldn't do that, you know?
But the reality is people
were upset when I stopped
so many of my projects.
"Ask Gary Vee", "DailyVee",
"WeeklyVee", which I'm doing.
You know how many people
are gonna hit me up
once Corona's over and say,
"Why'd you stop doing 'Tea
With GaryVee', it was
the best thing you did."
That's all I see on Twitter all day long,
this is the best thing I'm doing.
So, the reality is you're trying
to give as much as you can.
But then the reality is,
if you're not in a good place,
you have nowhere to give.
And this is gonna suck you out.
If you eventually aren't
doing what you want to do.
And who says you can't
write for a good three weeks
and then come hard with
a nice little video
and then go back.
You're being too anal
and structured on like,
"I got to put one out every three days,
or one day, or once a week."
You go do what you need to do,
and you pop in and make
a video when you want to.
- Okay.
- It's really that simple.
- Yeah, it really is, it really is.
But then you have people on your back
and it feels bad.
You get comments.
And then you also get caught
where the views aren't as good.
People get caught up in the
algorithms and the numbers.
They're like, "Damn, when
I was doing you know",
you come back, three weeks,
you put out thinking like,
"Damn, why is that 40,000
views instead of 80,000",
or 800,000 instead of 1.3 million,
whatever your world is.
So, the reality is, is that
if you're not doing you,
you're not going to be
able to do for them.
And so it starts with you.
The way to be selfless and give
is to actually be selfish
around knowing yourself.
That's what you need to do, Jaé.
- Okay.
I'll do that.
- Alright?
- One other question, one other question.
I live in Detroit, but
I want to be a writer,
which means I need to be a PA,
which means I need to move to Los Angeles.
And I have been struggling
with that decision,
because, well, it's expensive
as fuck in Los Angeles.
But I wanted to know from you,
if you were in my position
and you were a young writer, you haven't--
- I would try to write
one bomb ass masterpiece.
on some old "Good Will Hunting" shit
and put it out there
and if it doesn't take,
then I would go to move to LA
and fucking have a bullshit
job in the sunshine
and write and fucking chase my dream.
- Okay, I can do that.
- Got you.
- Thank you.
- Stay well.
- You too.
- You got it.
Take care.
- Be safe.
Alright, let's keep this going.
Fantasy Football Show, big ups on Twitter,
how are you?
I am wake.
What's up on YouTube? Good to see you.
Loving the comments coming in.
- Yo, what's good?
- Alex!
- How's it going, man?
It's good, bro, it's
going well, my friend.
- Good, hoping your
family is safe out there.
- Thank you, you too, bro.
- So, it's a question,
that's not really based around myself.
It's more based around a message that's
being sent out kind of in the media,
social media right now.
It's kind of saying you don't really need
to be productive during this time.
You know, a lot of people
are scared, uncertain.
There's been some people
that are getting depressed.
So, do you feel that's an okay message?
Or, how would you rephrase that message--
- Is that the message?
- Yeah, literally the headline is,
"You don't need to be
productive during this time."
- Yeah, I think what people
are trying to do there
is not put people in
a position of anxiety.
Right?
So, I think a much better word
would be anxious versus productive.
I think productive is
such a positive word.
You know, whether you're
productive on your mental health,
whether you're productive
on your physical health,
You know, I'm getting my
muscles going hard this time.
I think a lot of people get happiness
from being productive in their work.
You know, listen, I think this is why
putting out content's so hard.
We're in a headline
reading culture, right?
And even I can write 16 sentences
out of the video I make,
and I can soften the
title I put the video on,
people are immediately like,
"Oh, that's what people have to say."
So, my hope is that when you double-click
"You don't have to be productive",
what it's really talking about is like,
"Look, take a breath, don't
push yourself to anxiety.
"Don't burn yourself
out during this time."
Everyone's kind of at a standstill.
At the same token.
I think it's dangerous to put people
in the position of like, "I'm helpless,
"and can a bigger force
help me out of this?
Or take care of me?"
I think it leads to entitlement
and lack of accountability,
which often leads to great unhappiness.
So, I hope that people
are filtering it properly.
That's how I see it, Alex.
- Okay, yeah, that's, that's pretty much
what I was thinking you were gonna say,
I just wanted to kind of
hear it from the man himself.
It's such a subjective term to me,
there's so many different ways
for people to be productive.
It's not busting your
ass building a website,
you know, it's like writing
your feelings, whatever.
- Look, there's a very
clear grouping of like,
how do we find balance between hard work
and lack of burnout?
And I think that's powerful.
And for me, listen, as much
as I love hard work, and I do,
listen, I just haven't seen it.
I haven't seen the person that's made it
that didn't put in hard work.
I just haven't seen it.
I've seen people inherit
money and have money,
but they didn't make it. You know?
And by the way, most of
those people end up unhappy
because they didn't make it.
So, I think it's
important to be productive
and happy and satisfied.
That comes in a lot of different ways.
Some people go to India
for 14 days and meditate,
other people write for nine hours a day
with a glass of wine during this time.
I think it needs to be very personal.
I think balance is the key.
But I don't think we
should demonize hard work,
in the same way that we shouldn't demonize
meditation and passiveness.
This is a self-awareness game.
- That was it, man.
I think you said it, nailed it.
Productivity should be personal.
That was it, I was hoping for man.
So, that's all I really had.
- Stay well brother.
- I will.
- Take care yourself.
Speaking about wine,
Wine Text is lit.
I don't know if we have a
Wine Text banner, Dustin?
Oh! You guys are on it.
I'm telling you right now.
Where's my dad? I don't see him.
I'm telling you right now,
if you are not on this Wine Text game,
if you are buying wine
anywhere else on the internet,
I don't know, I got beef with you.
We might have to meet at the
flagpole, 3:30 after school,
and fucking fight, punching
people in the face.
This is the fucking thing
and today's is bonkers.
(mumbles) Today's is absolute
insanity, complete insanity.
So, here's the question for Twitter.
And everybody, actually,
here's a fun little break.
Here's the question.
Let's go macro, for a second.
Forget Wine Text, get that off the board.
Macro wine question.
What is your favorite wine?
Please reply.
#GaryVee on Twitter,
so Dustin and Wine Text
and others can find it.
What is your favorite wine?
So I can start bringing
more of that to Wine Text.
Alright, let's keep going.
Dustin, let's scroll people's
comments for 10:15's.
What's good?
- Hey, hello Gary, how's it going?
- It's going really
well, I love your shirt.
- Yeah, right on, hello from Maui.
- I love it. What's your name?
- I'm Zane Kekoa Schweitzer.
- It's a real pleasure.
- And I'm a professional waterman,
a world champion waterman published author
and, you know, when I was
thinking about a question
to ask you--
- Wait a minute, what
time is it back home?
- Oh, it's three in the morning (laughs).
- Yeah, hold on a sec, you know what,
this is what I want to say.
All the people that are
hitting me up on Twitter
in California and Oregon and Washington,
Arizona and crying about
6 a.m., look at this man.
Look at this man's commitment!
(laughs)
- I just got out of the water, man.
I was out night diving when I heard
that it was a late call for me.
I went out night diving,
out collecting some food for the family,
'cause as you know a lot of stores
are shutting down here in Hawaii.
That's on another note,
Maui keep the spirits up at this point,
'cause the question I had for you, Gary,
was something that I
was thinking, you know,
may be unique, and that's what
does happiness mean to you?
And how do you balance personal success
and financial success?
And do you see yourself as
having a healthy balance
of mind, body and spirit?
You know, you're a big
inspiration to me, Gary,
I follow you and a lot of your posts
throughout the social media platforms
and yeah, that's the question
I have for you--
- I appreciate it, brother,
I appreciate it.
So, mind, body and spirit,
and health, all that.
So, until six years ago,
my body, definitely not.
And I really got serious about health
and fitness on that level.
On the mind and happiness side, for sure.
This thing has been the
driving force for me forever.
For me, definition of happiness
is the ability to do what
you want to do every day.
Which is just a remarkable gift,
which is why I want so
many more people to go
into their passion and not worry
about making a million dollars,
but worry about making a million smiles
in their lifetime, right?
To me, the definition of happiness
for me is leaving a legacy.
There's so many contemporaries
I have in entrepreneur land,
who have no interest in
producing any content, Zane,
in doing any mentoring,
and it's so foreign to me.
They'd rather build empires
continuously for themselves,
and the people associated with them,
which I respect, 'cause I
absolutely have that gear in me.
But for me, I'd be so unhappy if I didn't
do "Tea With GaryVee" for free,
if I didn't put out all the content,
if I didn't try to leave a legacy,
If I didn't live a world
where I was getting emails
from kids that were
inspired and started stuff.
I have so much happiness
inside of me that I feel,
this is to shoot it
straight with you Zane,
a balance between
gratitude and even guilt.
You know, I understand that
the chemicals I was given
were right,
I understand the circumstances
of being an immigrant
to work right, which made me hungry.
You don't get to pick your parents,
I won that game.
So, you know, it's really hard for me
to not have a level of like,
"Wow, I have to give back."
Honestly, giving back
financially once you make it
is the easy part, if you can afford it,
writing a check.
I'm proud of the things I've
been doing during this time,
I keep that stuff quiet.
But punchline is buying
10s of thousands of masks
and donating them
comes a little bit easier
when you can afford it.
It's putting the time in.
Right now, I have a lot of fires.
I have a very intense day today.
I have big responsibilities
in maintaining people's jobs
and growing the company,
but I feel compelled to give
these two hours every morning
because as stressed as I am,
and as much as the gray
hairs are coming in
doing this kind of time,
I know that in these two hours,
a lot of good is being done.
There's a lot of people that
need my energy right now.
I can feel it.
And so I fucking have to do it.
- Man, that's right, you guys, your energy
definitely picks me up,
and you know that's a question
that actually hits home with me as well,
you know, as a professional athlete,
you even mentioned as well, you know,
that balance between guilt
and you said the balance--
- Gratitude.
- Guilt and gratitude.
And you know, my grandmother
always inspired me
to live life with the
attitude of gratitude and--
- Love that.
I think gratitude,
if gratitude and compassion and empathy
can become bigger, cooler words,
I think we can really win this game.
We just need a lot more
kindness in our society.
There's so much judgment and
there's so much triggering
to blame, there's so much anxiety.
And a lot of that comes
from actual entitlement.
If we were grateful for what we had,
versus envious of what we don't have,
and the things that people envy
are such fucking materialistic horseshit.
I wish people knew more multimillionaires
and realized how much
unhappiness is at that level.
If they really knew it,
if they really lived it,
if they really lived that anxiety
and insecurity of most, not all of course,
they would not aspire for it.
- Yeah, totally.
Well, I really appreciate that--
- Zane, I appreciate you, man.
- Sharing your time with us.
- I wish you nothing
but the best, brother.
Take care my friend, stay well.
Nick, thanks for being in the comments.
Geno Productions, big shout out to you.
I see you in the YouTube comments.
Shark Carter. Great to
see you, Shalone Carson.
Polina Why, thank you so much
for being on YouTube with us.
Crafty Belfast, what's good? Janelle.
A lot of YouTube comments,
I'm feeling that.
A lot of Twitter comments,
Not as many Facebook comments,
I need to see the
Facebook comments come on.
I'm ready, Dustin.
- So, the the Facebook
comments aren't coming in
because we had to set
up as a custom channel.
So, the platform doesn't
recognize it as being Facebook,
but I'm gonna figure
it out moving forward.
That way...
Yeah (laughs), I'll leave now.
- Yeah, I'll see you later Dustin.
Alright, Mr. Top Floor, what's good?
Chloe!
- Hi.
- Hi, how are you?
- Good, thanks, how are you?
- Awesome.
- Well, my question, it's
kind of like balancing.
I want to know your
perspective on balancing
running a business and my passion,
which is writing.
I wrote a book, I kind
of shopped it around,
I had some interest,
ultimately got rejected.
But they gave me really great advice
on my rejection letter.
But instead of (audio cuts) down there,
which I think would have been
the natural kind of response,
instead I went all in on my business.
And I now run a digital
kind of marketing agency
where I help out writers actually,
which I'm very passionate
about, it fulfills me.
I have one full-time person working for me
and five other part-time.
And I don't know, I just, I don't know,
when I sit down to write,
I think about business.
And my business is booming,
like people are reading more books now.
And I picked up two new clients
since this whole pandemic has started.
So, I'm in a really good spot.
And I don't know, I don't
know what you think.
I listen to your stuff all the time,
and I was like, "What would
Gary say in this situation?"
about kind of balancing those two.
- I would do them both.
And I would be okay
with if I'm in a moment
in my business that I go all
in for 87% on the business
and 13 on writing on the side.
Or even, by the way, 100.
You know, my great love in
business is Wine Library.
It was my first love, it
was my family business.
I went super hard.
And then I left and started VaynerMedia.
And during that time,
especially the years
three, four, five, six
and seven of VaynerMedia,
I really went all in on VaynerMedia.
Because years one and two,
I still had too many responsibilities,
I had to make sure Brandon and my dad
were good on Wine Library without me,
'cause I was really the leader there.
And then, a year ago, I just missed it.
I missed wine commerce
and I invented Wine Text,
you know, for my dad.
And so you might be able
to write in three years.
I think people make the mistake
and they think balance is a daily thing.
Balance is a life thing.
It's your whole life.
You're such a young woman.
Like, you might be able to
build your business up right now
to so much stability and save money
that you might be able to, in 11 years,
take two years off and
write your fucking novel.
- I guess--
- People, go ahead.
- I don't know.
I fear that if I let it go for too long,
it'll just be it and--
- Passions don't die.
Passions are your best friend.
They're sitting there, waiting for you,
whenever you come back.
They are, they're your best friends.
They're always there.
Sports cards have been
there, wine have been there.
You know?
Seven years ago, I went all GaryVee, 100%.
Built a humongous company,
have nothing but opportunity,
could go on and do all sorts of things.
And here I am at 44,
and two of the biggest things I talk about
are wine and sports cards,
my passions from when I was 15.
Two things that were not
coming out of my mouth
at all three years ago and
four years ago for the year.
I have a funny feeling, if
you look at all my content
three and four years ago,
I'm not sure if there's
a single mention of wine
or baseball cards, or sports cards.
Passions are always there.
They're just sitting over
there, your best friend,
just waiting for you to sit by the bench,
some fucking "Forrest Gump" shit.
Know what I'm saying?
- I understand (laughs).
- Balancing everybody
debates on a daily basis.
It's their number one mistake.
It's not a daily thing.
It's not a weekly thing.
It's not a monthly thing.
It's not even a yearly thing.
It is a full-life thing.
Your business is rocking right now.
It's okay to go 100% in for 36 months.
I promise you, pen and paper, laptop,
and fucking Word documents are sitting
right there waiting for you, open arms,
with a big hug and kiss and ready to go.
And by the way, you'll be a
different woman at that point.
And you might be able to be in a situation
where you might be even more creative.
- Yeah, can I ask you a
business question then?
- You can.
- I interviewed someone last week
to be my second full-time person.
And I had kind of started
recruiting months ago,
before all this happened.
And I found a person that
I think would do well
but I don't know now
if it's the time to take
on a full-time staff.
Like what I said, things
are moving up for me,
but I don't know if--
- I think as long as you
over-communicate with her,
like, "Hey, things are moving up for me,
"but it's uncertain,
anything could happen.
"I don't want to screw you.
"This is not the most stable situation,
"plus I'm a small company."
And give her the right to choose, or him.
- Where do you get your
clarity from? (laughs)
- You know what's funny,
I actually think, besides natural DNA,
and I always think I was born with wisdom,
I do think I'm an old soul,
I was very attracted to older
people when I was little,
I would always hang out with
like grandmas and grandpas
on the playground in
New York, in New Jersey.
Besides that, I actually
think it's a little bit
of a lack of education.
I'm not even kidding.
I think that I so didn't
conform to the school system,
and I so didn't pay attention,
starting in third grade,
that I was just in my own fucking world.
And I think in some weird ways,
that simplicity has been
a huge guiding light.
I keep it basic as fuck.
- And we all appreciate you
so much for that (laughs).
- Thank you so much.
I wish you well.
Take care of yourself.
Big shout out to Violet Jay
on YouTube, Ginger Beloved.
Facebook people, if you
want to get your comments
shouted out or pinned,
you can switch over to
Twitter or YouTube Live.
Lots of comments coming through there.
Andrew, what's up? Brad
Rotor, what's good?
Eli Murphy, what is good?
How do I make money as a middle schooler
during this quarantine?
Eli, sell every single thing in your room
on eBay and Facebook marketplace.
Chris!
- Hey, how's it going, Gary?
- It's really good, it's good to see you.
- You were talking about
seven, eight years ago,
and like check that out (laughs).
That was a video you made me seven,
almost eight years ago,
when I had a tiny, tiny, little office.
And you talk about documenting,
here we are eight years later,
and I'm going to ask you a question
about like a national company I have.
And a lot of that is is you, man.
So, first of all, thank you very much.
Getting right down to it.
Business owners, this is for
like the leadership people
that are following you,
the people that followed
you eight years ago
that now, if they've
listened, they've got--
- Have something.
- Yeah.
- So, it's a difficult
time with the pandemic
and everything else.
Like, what advice do you
give to leaders like myself
with not only keeping the
synergy of a team intact,
but also morale and everything else.
Because like every employee's
thinking of layoffs,
financial times, everything else.
What's your advice to the leaders on here?
- Communication and clarity.
Literally, 11 o'clock, I
go on with a 20 person call
of 20 leaders of Vayner,
give them the update of
what I see this week,
and then at 11:30 today I go and address
the entire organization on
live stream for 30 minutes.
And I'm gonna tell them the truth.
Lots of optimism, lots of opportunity
and lots of unsettling lack of data.
When you don't have good information,
it's hard to make good decisions.
And a lot of issues at our client level,
you know, bankruptcies, payment delays,
lots of stuff.
Muckery, muckery, muckery.
And so, I'm going to try to
find the balance of inspiration
and transparency, which is very difficult,
because most people will
not hear the inspiration,
they'll hear the fear.
If I lead to anything, like,
"Oh, some of our clients
"might go out of business",
and thus immediately everyone's like,
"I'm getting fired."
So, you know, I'm worried about that.
So, I'm gonna try to find that balance.
I'm gonna address that on, right?
I'm gonna speak to that.
At some point, I'm gonna say
something that's transparent.
And then I'm going to feel it and say,
"Guys, I know you sitting here
right now in your house, and
"you're like, 'Ugh, that means
we're gonna have huge lay--'"
Listen, if you're great, you're fine.
If you're contributing, you're fine.
Obviously, we'll have to look
at the reality of the situation.
But, I've been looking at how much we pay
for bananas and how
much we pay for candles
and how much we pay for
cleaning our offices
to do anything I can
possibly do to save jobs.
That is my number one priority.
And I just have to speak that truth.
- Yeah, that's never talked about, right?
How efficient our businesses
come when you suddenly
have to look at it in a
different perspective, right?
- Of course.
No matter how frugal you are,
- No matter how CFO driven you are,
there's always an opportunity
to cut more costs, always.
- Are you still getting the workouts in?
- I am.
(laughs)
I'm feeling pretty good,
I'm feeling like it's coming together.
I've been working out every day.
Mike and I are teleconferencing in
on FaceTime on the laptop.
I've been feeling pretty good about that.
I'm feeling good about that
and I'm up for this challenge.
It's super painful.
A friend of mine said a good
analogy the other day about
if you have to let people go.
It's like being in the forest
and a tree falls on your leg.
And whoever the park ranger's like,
"Look, you're gonna die if
we don't cut off your leg."
And you cut off your leg
and you fucking love your leg,
you don't want to let
go of anybody right now.
But if you can't make payroll,
then the whole thing dies.
If you can't pay your bills, or debt,
or whatever it might be for people.
And so, this is real life.
It's a liquidity event and
you've got to be a professional.
A lot of people have small businesses
and don't have overhead
and they just need to be more
humble in their own lives.
And then other people like ourselves
have a lot of employees, so
we've gotta look at everything.
- It's like everything
you've always talked
about though, right?
If you're just real, if you're human,
and you're keeping them informed.
I talked to management team last week,
the other, in the other brands,
and it was just like, if you're
having those conversations,
you're bringing those fears
to life in a good way.
You know what I mean?
- In a good way.
- Yeah, you're keeping them informed,
they know what might happen,
and yeah, anyways, man, I appreciate you.
We were supposed to connect in Edmonton,
but then it got canceled.
- I know, I know, I'm coming back though.
Edmonton is not gonna be fully canceled.
That one's postponed,
I will be in Edmonton.
- That is fantastic.
Thanks for everything you do.
- I'll see you then.
- We love you.
- Thank you, Chris.
Stay well, love you back.
Chris, I've known for
a long time in social.
Thomas, good to see you, Crispy.
Thank you for watching.
Berry Stella, thank you for
making this your first Tea time.
Dustin, let's throw up a
bunch of people's comments
on the screen.
People like that, little moments.
Five, seven seconds, I'm fine with it,
just rapid fire.
- Okay.
- A lot of people, a lot of love.
- Yeah, they go by really quick,
so I'm trying not to hit the ones
that say like "fuck you"
or something (laughs).
- That's fine, I'll take that.
You know I fucking feed
off that shit, Dustin.
I love the fuck yous.
- Okay, okay.
- I equally love the goat and fuck you.
I love them both, I love it all.
- Okay.
- I ain't scared of shit.
I can't hear it anyway.
Let's go.
What I mean by can't hear
it if you don't know me
is don't get too high, don't
get too low with comments.
Anthony, what's good?
- Hey, Gary.
I can't believe I'm
talking to you right now.
It's crazy.
- Thank you, brother.
- So, just to give you
a little bit of clarity,
I'm a Twitch streamer,
I'm actually using my setup right now.
I've been streaming on Twitch
for the last two years.
I started while I was in school.
I kind of threw myself back into it,
I'm getting more serious with it
as of the last six months,
and then lately I've just
been doing it every day.
I've been having like incremental success
with a few follows here and
there and a couple of subs.
And I'm really happy
about it, I get excited.
But I just kind of wanted to ask you,
how do I differentiate myself
between other streamers maybe
that are smaller or bigger.
I feel like
it's so saturated.
- Of course it's saturated!
And it should be.
So as YouTube influence should be.
It's a free platform
where you can do what you
fucking love and make money.
The world's saturated, brother.
- Okay.
- Everyone's like, "Oh, Gary,
TikTok's now saturated."
I'm like, "Yeah?"
They're like, "Oh,
Twitch is saturated now."
Yeah? It's supposed to be!
The way to differentiate
is to be 100% you.
I'll give you a huge piece of advice.
Don't watch a single other streamer.
- Really?
- Really.
Because what ends up happening
is you subconsciously
start taking some of their flavor,
and then you just start
looking like everybody else.
I think one of the reasons I
don't look like anybody else
is 'cause I don't consume anybody else.
And I think a lot of people
are different than me
and are really good at
looking at other people
and taking good value from them.
So, I don't think it's a
100% all or nothing thing,
but I think most people need
to start getting to a place
where they consume other people less,
so they can find their own fucking voice.
- Okay.
I mean, I don't, like for instance,
I don't know if you know who Nickmercs is?
But like--
- I do.
- Okay, I watch him,
but I don't compare myself.
I more or less watch him
because he's really good
at like shooters and I play
a lot of COD--
- Yeah, I get that.
I get that, I respect that,
and it's not like you should
not use it for entertainment.
My concern is that anytime
you start comparing
to anybody else, big or small,
it gets into this competitive...
Most people are in this game
of worrying about numbers,
and worrying about tactics.
And I'm concerned about that.
Whereas what I really think
will actually break you out
is being yourself,
telling stories about who
you are while you're playing,
like fucking how you beat up
Ricky Thompson in third grade.
Like, it's storytelling.
It comes down to connecting
with the audience.
And I think that that's
what you need to focus on.
You need to show more of yourself.
The only competitive advantage we all have
is our unique stories, us.
- Okay, I think you've said this before
that anytime you're a content creator,
or like with Twitch streaming,
it's between you're either
really good at the game,
or you're funny, like
those are the two things
that kind of work.
- Or you can be kind of
funny and kind of good
and 100% you and fucking dominate.
- Okay, I guess my follow up question--
- Because funny is
happening now no different
than dancing on TikTok.
But I promise you, somebody
is about to go on Twitch
and be a psychologist while they play
and fucking bring mindset to kids.
Bro, I'm not good at games,
I'm telling you right now,
if I started playing
old school Nintendo shit
that I was decent at, and
fucking old Sega Genesis,
but fucking started dropping knowledge
for three hours for the kids,
I'd have a humongous Twitch channel.
- Shit, that's true.
- So you just need to be you.
Like, talk about what you know.
Talk about real life.
Talk about your heart getting broken,
talk about why your uncle inspires you.
Talk about, like, you know
why you were impressed
by Bugha winning the
fucking Fortnite tournament.
Like, talk about shit!
- Okay.
- Open up more
while you're playing.
- Alright, I'm trying to like
teach myself Adobe Premiere so I can like
put out more videos and stuff.
I've actually been talking...
Hello?
- Everything's phenomenal, go ahead.
- Oh, okay, so I've been
trying to put out more stuff
but the follow up question was,
should I even try to look
for that next big game
to get good at--
- Yes!
- To then try and like
go from there?
- Yes!
Yeah, that's like in eSports,
that's like TikTok and
Instagram and YouTube.
If you catch the next big game,
and you're fucking g at it,
it's gonna fucking matter.
Absolutely, I think
that's a good use of time.
- Okay, because I've been
looking at Valor and stuff
and I, but yeah--
- By the way, why am I
always early in winning?
Everyone's like, "GaryVee,
TikTok, Snapchat, Facebook!"
It's because I'm not scared.
Everybody brings up TikTok
and Facebook and Twitter.
Nobody talks about the two
months I wasted on Plurk.
Nobody talks about the three
months I wasted on Social Camp.
Nobody talks about the five months
I wasted on Photo Booth,
or Daily Booth, excuse me.
I'm not scared.
If a new game came out
called "Jackson Arrows",
and I got fucking gnarly at it,
but nobody gave a fuck,
I wouldn't dwell that I spent
seven months getting great
at fucking "Jackson Arrows".
- True.
- Everyone's fucking
scared of wasting time
when their fucking time ain't worth shit.
It's called entitlement.
Everybody's fancy, thinks they're special.
Like, why are you people worried
about fucking wasting time,
when they're actually
investing, to Chris Kim's point,
in understanding shit.
Because by the way, the time I wasted
on fucking Daily Booth
and fucking Social Camp
is the reason I fucking understood
Vine, Snapchat, IGTV, TikTok.
- So then if you moved that over to games
if that Jack game you just talked about,
the mechanics can still
be transferred over.
(clicking)
Like oh you still are good
at shooting in Jack game,
you could still be good at
shooting in this other game.
That, oh my god, that
clicked, holy shit! (laughs)
- All I'm trying to do is eliminate fear.
People are scared of wasting time
when their time ain't worth shit.
I mean, I can't.
The entitlement and the
audacity that comes along with,
"Oh, I don't want to waste my time!"
What the fuck are you
doing otherwise, jerk?
- Damn, Gary. Fuck.
- What's your Twitch handle?
I want to make sure
everybody gets a watch.
- Oh, This Is Arche.
So T-H-I-S is I-S
and then Arche A-R-C-H-E.
- A-R-C-H-E.
- Yes.
- Awesome.
Check him out, fellas.
See you.
- Thank you so much, Gary.
- Take care.
That was a good one.
Team GaryVee, let's chop that one.
There's something there.
I want that as an IGTV, ASAPO.
Don't even test it, get some headlines.
Let's fucking go.
- Hey, Gary.
- Hey, Megan, how are you?
- Good, I just want to
say shout out to you
for making me self-aware enough to know
that I'm not meant to be a number one
on any day of the week.
- Good for you.
But I do I do make a kick ass number two.
So, I leaned into that pretty hard.
So, I work with a creative
real estate investor,
and our goal is to make
creative real estate investing
a tool for everyone to build wealth.
And we lead with people first,
because we truly do believe
it is a people business.
So, our question to you is,
how can we become a
national real estate icon
and scale in order to support that.
- Content.
- Okay, so I have a question
when it comes to content.
Because I was like, "I
know what he's gonna say."
(laughs)
We have trouble kind of breaking down
difficult topics into
small, consumable pieces.
- That's because the person
who's communicating is longwinded.
- Okay, so what is the best way you
can kind of give us to break
down a complicated topic
into a fourth grade or fifth
grade level understanding?
- Decks are good.
I don't know if you've
ever seen my content?
- Oh, I've seen it.
- For everybody's watching,
Google GaryVee content deck,
it'll help a lot of you.
So decks are good. Cartoons, animations.
Listen, humans do it.
I take complex as shit
stuff and really break
it down to first grade level.
- Right.
- You just might have a
longwinded communicator.
Which is okay.
- Right.
- Either that person
can train to get tighter
and more concise, or
you find somebody else
as a human being to consume it,
excuse me, to communicate it.
- Awesome. Okay, cool.
No, that makes sense.
So, when we're building a brand,
Do you recommend having it
be under a personal name,
so, like, let's just say Megan.
Or under--
- Both work.
- Okay, both? Would you
do both at the same time?
So, would you do like a
niche specific business name
and your personal name?
- Sure, Steve Jobs is a brand,
Apple is a brand, right?
Both can work, it just
comes down to the human
and it comes down to the business.
- So, when it comes to finding people
to make the animations,
would you just recommend a normal Fiverr
or something like that? Or Upwork?
Because we have been having
trouble trying to find people
to make the animations and the drawing.
So if anybody does that! (laughs)
- Say your Twitter handle,
let people hit you up.
What's your Twitter handle?
- So the Twitter handle is @CoryJCalvin.
- Spell it.
- C-O-R-Y-J-C-A-L-V-I-N.
- I love it.
Guess what, you just found an animator.
- Thank you, I'm super excited!
- Oh, here it is, good job.
Dustin, doing nice work.
There is the actual handle.
Megan, thank you so much for calling in.
- Thank you, Gary. Bye!
- Yeah, same, bye, bye.
Alright, let's see what's
going on here, more comments.
Magic Brad, what's good?
Thank you for watching.
Mr. Topler, what's good?
Chris Vargas. Appreciate it.
Elementary Flips.
If you want your question on the show,
please hit me up on 212-931-5731,
212-931-5731
Let's do it.
Clem!
How are you?
- Hi, I'm fine, thank you.
I was pretty excited to be--
- Where are you from?
- I'm from Austria, so Central Europe.
- Very nice, I know it well.
- By the way, I also started in wine.
I'm a wine grower by training.
- Very nice.
- And I ditched all of
that to follow my passion,
which is this thing behind me.
- Good for you.
- So a while back, I got into tinkering
with electronics mostly.
And now I made that hobby my job.
And a few days ago, I turned 33.
And I said to myself, why not gift myself,
the company that I would
also like to start?
So, I make a second venture,
because my own brand is
totally dependent on me.
So, I can't source anything out.
I have to do it myself.
But I want to grow that and
maybe employ people someday.
So I got a new hobby.
This is an RC scale crawler.
- Yeah.
- It's pretty much a competition thing.
And it's getting really popular currently.
And also people are building them
in the quarantine, currently.
So I made a little invention.
So you see the chassis, that's my design,
and I also fabricate these things.
So I'm trying to take,
not really advantage,
but I'm trying to encourage
people to not spend
more money than they could
afford on such a machine.
That one is designed to
be extremely variable.
And so people can use used and old parts
to build new competition legal machines.
- That's fucking awesome.
- So they can have fun
on a budget.
So I want to launch that later that year.
But first, I want to
create a lot of content
around this because it's a product
that you need to explain a lot.
- Understood.
Should I spend a lot of time
and effort and obviously also money
on making a juggernaut of content
that is ready on launch?
Or should I, only the main things,
and fill out what people want?
- Number two.
I would be putting out
content as often as possible
to get feedback.
Because if you spend a lot of time,
money and energy on a ton
of content that nobody sees,
you're not using the
internet's feedback loop
to get smarter.
You're using a 1985 model.
In the same way that you're
innovating on the chassis,
I want you to innovate on content.
No reason to do it like they
used to do it and guess,
you can be putting out content every day,
and seeing the feedback
and getting a sense
of what really resonates.
It's really cool that this is popping.
and I know this has been
getting more and more popular
in Europe in general.
And it was very big in
the US in the early '90s.
Big shout out to my friend Robbie Turnik.
I remember he had a car
and I remember a lot of
people were getting into it
and it's gonna be interesting
to see how global this gets
and how much this will
play into the US or Asia.
But I think you're in a
very interesting niche
that has a ton of opportunity.
- I think because the
regulations on RC flying,
which I was into before,
it got so strong and so restrictive
that you're basically not
allowed to go anywhere to fly it.
So I have to travel about 100 kilometers
to be legally able to fly.
So, I scrap those and
focused on the crawlers.
- Do you have a YouTube channel?
- Yes.
- What is it?
- I'm working for an
American YouTube channel
called element14 Presents,
so that's a channel that
revolves around electronics,
that is where I get my money
and my project fundings.
I closed down my own little channel
to focus on that.
- Understood.
- And of course, I will do a new channel,
probably called Trail
Bug, like the company.
- Train Bug, Trail Bug.
Nice.
- Yeah.
And do a lot of content there,
and I also have the
opportunity to get a property
where I can legally film,
which is also an issue.
And build like a training facility there,
to have events and film
other people's cars there,
and maybe even have my own racing team,
with drivers that I
endorse with my product.
- I love that.
- Is that a good idea?
- Yeah, I think you're
well on your way.
I like everything that's
coming out of your mouth.
- Okay.
- I think you need to put out more content
on TikTok and Instagram daily. Daily.
- Is there something that you think
that would specifically work
well on those platforms?
- I'm not sure, but you need to test.
Even if I fully did,
you'd still have to
interpret it and make it.
You have to make, you have to make.
In the same way that you
tinkered to figure it out,
you need to tinker with content.
- A hard thing.
- In the same way that it's impossible
for me to do what you do, right,
it's hard, like I'm not handy.
I don't even want to fucking
put a picture on the wall,
let alone build a fucking chassis.
Fuck that, you know?
So I get it.
So, maybe so maybe you take some money
and you hire an intern,
who, she or he, is very
passionate about making content.
- Yeah, that would be a thing.
I'm more the--
- The maker. I get it, I get it.
When you can't do it,
bringing somebody in at a low cost.
There's so many people that are passionate
about making content.
By the way, there's young kids in Austria,
specifically in Austria,
let alone Europe right now,
who desperately want one of your cars
but can't afford it.
Yet, they're unbelievable
at making content
for the internet.
We need to be thinking more about barter.
You can make a video right now
on your small, little YouTube channel
that you closed down, repopulated up,
even if there's 25
people who are watching,
make a video and say,
"I will make four cars
for you, which has value.
"You make a lot of content for me.
"Who wants to barter, who wants to trade?"
We need a lot more trade.
I see the Internet bringing
back a lot of old school habits.
One of the old school habits,
long before there was money,
was we were trading.
I raised cattle, you raise
vegetables, we trade.
You could make a coat, I
could make a meal, we trade.
You're fucking unbelievable
at what you do.
There's somebody right now,
probably two miles away from you,
who's unbelievable at
making TikToks and YouTubes,
and is enjoying what you do,
and you can make that trade.
- Yeah, it's a probably a thing the first,
after I post the first prototypes,
like the first one was an input,
so I could cut it on my
little laser just in there.
And immediately, somebody said,
"Will you sell them? Can
I get them somewhere?"
- Trade, barter, trade.
- So that initially
got me to that.
Okay, so, content.
- Alright Clem, take care.
- Content. And if you can't do it,
find somebody who can
and either pay them or trade them.
- Yeah.
- Take care.
Rohit said you got an
extra 100 subscribers,
I wonder if he's talking
about that channel he's on.
Let's see.
(laughs) What is Tinder?
I love people so much.
Waste Roaches with the ha has.
- Ah!
- DJ, what's good?
- What's going on, Gary?
Thank you so much
for having me on.
- I like that Empathy
in the back. I love your
little shrine back there, bro.
I see your content on Twitter.
I always appreciate you.
- Oh, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you for everything.
I'm gonna keep it short and sweet,
'cause I know you're busy.
I sell real estate and I
had a super successful year
last year, thank you
so much for everything.
Thank you for allowing
me to leave my day job,
ooh this getting off of...
I'm there in front of my clients
but I want to try to start to tell them,
"Hey, this is how you save your house,
"or you may have to downsize."
I've had clients who bought
huge homes, smaller homes.
I don't know if everybody
is still working or not.
How do I approach that
conversation without being such
doom and gloom?
Is there like a few ways to do it?
- With your former clients,
to check in on where they're at?
Is that what you're asking?
- Yeah, I've been checking in,
but I haven't broached the,
"Hey, how are you financially?"
- I think a nice way to do it
is potentially sending everybody
chocolate, flowers, wine
with a note that says,
"Hey, it's me, just trying to brighten up
"your day during this time.
"And I'm here for any
conversation professionally
"that you need, let me know."
I think that that's a
way to put in a deposit
on a 20, 30, $50 investment on somebody
on the other side, and
a sweet way to do it.
And if you really write,
"Hey, just sending you this
nice bottle of Empathy,
"'cause I've got empathy
during this situation.
"Speaking of which, if there's anything
"I could talk to you about professionally,
"if you need me in any way, on
business, here's my number."
I think it would work.
- Yeah, because what I've been doing,
I always send out like the holiday cards,
and the text, and the email, or whatever.
- People don't want that shit.
People don't want
that shit.
- Yeah, they want the real--
- People want some shit.
- They want the real--
- They want flowers.
- They want real
advice now, because--
- Well, I actually think
they want some stuff.
Like right now, people
are sitting at home.
Ding dong, FedEx.
After they wipe it down,
they're scared for a day or two,
they open it up and
there's a bottle of wine.
If there's flowers, if there's
chocolate-covered pretzels,
that's a nice thing to do.
- Okay, so on your other
site, your site for the store,
does that deliver also
so I can get the treats delivered as well?
- Oh, yeah. And by the way,
wine's complicated, obviously
Empathy can ship everywhere,
Wine Library, WineText can't.
There's also, by the way,
alcohol is like, wine's a 70% thing.
I think chocolate's a 70% thing.
I think flowers is an 80% thing.
Plus, go back to your memory bank
and remember some of the
shit that you were talking
about with those people.
Maybe you remember that
they're a Minnesota Vikings fan
and you send them something like that.
So just be creative and thoughtful.
- Okay.
- I do think Empathy...
I'm ironically wearing the Empathy hat.
I gotta talk the Empathy team.
I do think the "I have
empathy during this time"
kind of like transition and
no card is kind of fresh.
Anyway, go ahead.
- I was thinking like for...
If you, uh oh...
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
If there were like some other things
to buy with that
because the branding is awesome for that.
- Thank you.
- Are you guys coming out
with anything else that we can send?
- Not yet.
You know, I'm a big fan
of like settling the base.
- Uh oh, I lost your audio.
- I wanna get the wine brand...
Oh, you did? I'm sorry.
Can everybody else hear me?
Dustin, can you hear me?
- Yeah, I could still hear you.
- I can hear you.
You can hear me?
- Okay.
I just couldn't hear him.
- No worries.
Not yet, brother, but we're working on it.
- Okay, I just couldn't
hear you, I'm sorry.
- No worries.
- Thanks Gary!
- I hope you have a great day,
take care.
- I appreciate it.
- Great to see you.
- Follow me on Twitter,
if you can.
- I will.
- DJ Reality Solutions on Twitter.
- I will do it.
- Thank you!
- You got it, brother.
Long Game Life, what's good?
Dustin, I see.
I see a barber shop with
eight locations in Jersey.
Team Gary, let's get
that person to the queue
for tomorrow's "Tea With GaryVee".
- Cool.
- Same with Lord Adam,
Lord Adam on YouTube
is asking a good question.
Lord Adam, if you can go to
Twitter, ask that question,
or Team, whoever's community
managing YouTube right now.
Hit up Lord Adam. Let's
get them into the queue
for Wednesday or Thursday.
Preston!
- Hey, Gary, how are you?
- I'm well, man.
Thank you so much for all
the Twitter interaction.
I've been seeing you a lot.
- Yeah, well, it's been fun.
Thanks for having me on.
My heart is racing right now.
This is super cool, I
really appreciate it.
- Thank you, where are
you from by the way?
- I live in Atlanta.
Born and raised.
- Awesome, awesome.
I saw John Abraham's. You know, huge fan,
love that guy.
- Yes.
- And when he left.
- I loved him.
He was literally one of my
favorite Jets of all time.
- Yeah, he's for sure up there.
Tony Gonzalez, another big
favorite of mine for Falcons.
- He's a good friend of mine,
really good person.
- Cool.
So, again, really appreciate it,
been following you for a couple years.
So, for a little bit of background,
I just started a healthcare company,
a medical device company
selling surgical products
to hospitals.
So, as you can imagine, in this time,
the last, you know, month or so,
we really haven't been able to do a lot.
Especially on the sales front,
you know, you call a hospital
for all the right reasons,
they don't have time
to talk about anything.
- 'Course, 'course.
- And we don't have what they are needing
in this current time.
So, as a result of that,
we've stopped all of our sales activities
because we don't want
to be bothering them.
- That's right, tone-deaf.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So, my question is,
instead of just hitting
the pause button on everything for month,
two months, however long,
what can we be doing in terms
of either building community,
building our brand,
without being tone-deaf?
I don't want to be pushing out
tons and tons of stuff.
- I got it, I got it.
I think it's storytelling around you
and the journey of how you got there.
You've heard that from me,
I know you're paying attention.
I'm a big fan of leveling
up in Facebook groups.
So, I think starting a
Facebook group that might be
called like "Atlanta Entrepreneurs"
is not a horrible idea.
Or "Atlanta Health and
Wellness Professionals".
You know, like creating a Facebook group
and taking all your channels and energy
and trying to build up that group.
And then starting,
once you get 50 people into that group,
starting a nightly Zoom or Hangout,
or StreamYard, with 10, 15, 20 people.
Those kind of things,
well StreamYard's a little bit different,
but Zooms and Google Hangouts
where you could do happy
hours and just shoot the shit.
I would become a bigger local presence.
- Okay.
- Because you have to understand,
the hospital professionals
are not going to join that
because they're busy as fuck.
- Right.
- When that doctor is married to a guy
who has a landscaping business
and he's part of the group,
when he loves you because
you were the fucking creator
of the group and he's your homie,
and when it's all over in August
when you have dinner in Buckhead
with him and his wife,
who happens to be a fucking doctor
or a lead person in the hospital,
you see how it works?
- Yeah.
- People say no
because they don't see the chess move.
They only see the move in front of them.
And they're like, "I'm not
starting a Facebook group!
"All the fucking hospital professionals
"that I want are fucking tied up!"
I'm like, "Right, and
that's why I get to be me
"and you get to be you."
What you're not thinking
about is A, the karma of
putting together a nice group,
which is nice.
B, the reality is it's just really nice
to fucking do that kind of karma stuff,
get friends, things that nature.
And then C, most of all,
humans are connected to humans.
Literally, a dentist is
gonna join your group,
is gonna be on a Zoom, is gonna meet up
once we can meet in real, you know,
you're gonna have this
group that you get together
with every two nights for cocktails.
Well, you know what's
gonna happen July 19,
they're all gonna get
together in real life.
And that dentist has
literally single best friends
went to Georgia Tech with the fucking head
of fucking mount this,
mount that hospital X,
and you're fucking on your way.
People aren't strategic,
people aren't patient,
people aren't kind, people
aren't willing to give
with nothing in return.
People aren't patient to
let relationships play out
for three years.
And people aren't strategic.
They don't even see it.
So, I'm fucking dropping
knowledge right now, Preston,
that's the real thing.
'Cause guess what? It's
better than sitting around.
- Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
I've been certainly, guess more on
the hospital, people
who work in healthcare.
- Chess, chess,
chess.
- Yeah.
When we first started, I wanted to put out
a lot of educational kind of things.
- That's good, that's good.
- Health,
business administration.
- That's good.
But this is a unique time
when people get stuck
and starting an entrepreneurs
helping entrepreneurs
in Atlanta group would be a
really good idea right now.
And by the way, for the
10s of thousands of people
that are watching, just
replace the word Atlanta,
with Birmingham, or
Louisville, or Salt Lake City,
or fucking Aspen, and away you go,
Host the virtual party during this time.
Become the head of the
Chamber of Commerce,
become the mayor, virtually,
of the entrepreneurship community
by starting a Facebook group
using all your other channels,
email, text.
People are like, "Gary, but I don't have
"a lot of social media followers."
I'm like, "Do you have an address book?"
They're like, "Yeah."
I'm like, "Start at A, end with a Z,
"and text people the URL
to the Facebook group
"and say, 'Yo, you wanna join this?'"
And then once you get 19 or 23,
the virality starts kicking in.
- Okay, yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
Can I ask you
one more quick thing?
- Yeah.
- I'm super active on LinkedIn,
I like healthcare things personally.
I have a set LinkedIn
page for the company.
It's just sort of a small tactical thing,
I'm in the comments of
people all the time,
sharing thought leaders, things
like that, for the company,
I mean we post and we put out articles,
things like that.
As a company, do you typically
like jump in comments,
like interact the same way
that is just your good person?
- Yeah and you can do
the logo of the company
and then at the end of your comment
you can put "dash Preston Alexander".
- Okay.
- Got it?
- Yeah, perfect, awesome.
- Awesome.
- Good day, thanks.
- Stay well.
Fucking giving out tactics!
What a first hour of Tea With Gary Vee.
Let's go to Twitter real quick.
I'm just going to go,
hold on one second Dustin,
don't throw anybody up,
I'm just going to go to
Twitter in my own app
to see what's going on here.
Ooh, Empathy Wines is heavy,
go in there, Craig Kaplan.
Craig Kaplan, you're getting a follow.
Boom, I'm your 148th follower.
Craig, I also want you on a...
I also want you...
Yeah, that's awesome,
equipment and beyond.
Tea Time Kyle K, big ups to you, brother.
Okay, right now, everybody who's watching,
take a screenshot of this
and post it on Twitter.
Take a screenshot of the next
guest and post it on Twitter
with #TeaWithGaryVee and put up the URL
to YouTube or Facebook in it.
And we'll be doing some following.
Let's keep going.
Bradley!
- Hey, what's going on Gary?
- Oh, it's good, bro.
Where are you from?
- I'm in Cedar Falls, Iowa.
Small town up here.
- Awesome.
I know it.
- Gosh, it is so cool
to be talking to you.
- Thank you.
- Oh my gosh, I have to thank
you for something real quick.
You had a IGTV post, probably
at least a month ago now,
it was talking about, I don't
remember who you were with,
but you were in a room
with a chick and probably
like her manager,
and you were talking about
who to associate with
and how to post on social,
and things like that.
I don't know if you know
what I'm talking about.
- With Chessie?
- Maybe, yeah.
Anyways, you were you
were talking about, like,
people associate with me
because I'm a Jets fan,
or people talk to me,
because I, you know, that thing.
And that revolutionized
the way that I think
about, like, I have an advertising agency,
that revolutionized the
way that I think about that
and the way that I talk to my clients
about how they post on social
and giving them advice,
so I just want to thank you for that.
- That was--
- That's awesome.
- Fantastic.
- Happy to do it.
- Okay, my question is, I'm a really,
really ambitious person.
And I struggle sometimes
with setting goals
that are way, way too high,
because I want the
world and I want it now,
and I really try and practice patience,
but sometimes it's not always easy.
So, anyways, I set these
goals really, really high.
And when I don't end up hitting them,
because nine times out of 10--
- Well, that's because you
put a timeline on them.
- True.
- You're a fucking child!
(laughs)
You're a fucking child.
And what do you mean you haven't hit them?
You put a time limit on them.
There's nothing worse than
putting a time limit on a goal.
There's nothing worse.
There's no more guaranteed
way to be sad and anxious
and get fucked up,
than to put a time limit on a goal.
An age to get married,
an age to have kids,
an age to make your
first hundred thousand,
an age to retire, an age to quit your job.
There's nothing more guaranteed
in fucking yourself up
than putting a time
limit on an actual goal.
- Okay, okay.
So, to kind of change that around,
I've also tried in the past making
really, really small goals,
and like making it something that I can
accomplish in like a day.
- Achieve? (laughs)
- Or like a week, yeah.
But then I always--
- How do you like those?
- I always end up feeling
like I could have done more.
Like, I think they're effective
because I get stuff done,
but I always feel like
I could have done more,
or I don't feel like I
was maximizing my efforts
in what I was doing,
- I think you have a really
bad relationship with time.
And I think if we can hack that,
in the same way that we hacked
the ideas around content,
I think you could have
a real breakthrough.
You know? Like to me, you
just have this fascination,
this need, to create timeframes,
which are both upsetting you.
Think about what you just broke down.
I make bullshit goals and I achieve them
and of course subconsciously,
I feel like shit, 'cause I
know I fucking sandbagged it.
I make these monster fucking goals
that are completely unachievable,
and you're just fucking yourself up.
You're judging yourself.
- Okay, so--
- Stick with me on this one.
- Okay.
- This is the most
important part.
- Okay.
- You're judging yourself.
- Yeah, I am.
You're right, I am.
- For no fucking reason!
- How do I--
- How? Well, easy.
A, we just spent time this
morning, thank God, for...
You know, everybody thinks
of COVID as a bad thing
and then they don't realize the person
that would have died in
a car accident, right?
God rest his soul, one of
my buds Nipsey Hussle dies
a year ago during the COVID time.
If COVID happened last
year, he'd be alive.
So people don't see the positive.
You know COVID led to me and you,
I wouldn't be fucking doing "Tea Time".
You know? Here we are.
So, how do you do it?
You take the fucking
gratitude and blessing
of this fucking chance encounter,
where we fucking zoom in
on it, fucking pure set it,
right? Now you know it.
Now it's fucking out there,
10s of thousands of people saw it,
I know it, you know it.
Best of all, you know it.
So now that we know it,
we take a step back.
A, did that judgment get into my brain
because my mom and dad judged me,
and now I've taken on that voice,
manipulated it like a virus
and it's inside of me?
And do I cut it out?
Two, I clearly worry too much
about what other people think
because I'm trying to
create these arbitrary goals
to flex them or to put them on a mantle
so you can see my fucking trophy.
Those are the two things that I'm best at.
I'm best at not fucking
hearing a single thing
and not judging myself.
And two, I have no interest
in flexing on anybody
about anything because I don't give a fuck
if you think I'm great or I suck.
- So you're saying keep
the goals out there,
regardless of how--
- Or, make a monster goal professionally.
You know, like buying the New York Jets.
- Yes.
- And not put a time limit on it.
And realize the reason
you have that crazy goal
is not because you actually
want to buy the New York Jets,
it's because you love being
an entrepreneur so much
that you're creating a
goal that's so far away,
that you can fucking play this game
that you love more than breathing
for the rest of your fucking life.
- I love that, I love that.
I love that, that's fantastic.
What, so...
Okay, wow, that's--
(laughs)
I know, I love it, that's fantastic--
- No, it's good, man.
Like, listen, it's--
- I didn't realize that
I put a timeframe on it.
But I did, you're right.
- I know.
On some bullshit.
- You're right.
Yeah.
- It's bad.
- Yeah, no, it is.
- It's the recall of the
beginning of this video,
bro, you know how fun
it is to start getting
these gray hairs, because
now I really understand.
It was in me at your age, at a young age,
but now I'm through a lot of reps.
I've seen a lot of patterns.
I've watched millions of people,
hundreds of thousands intimately,
I've watched that, all I do is watch,
and I'm telling you, this
is the fucking framework.
- Okay, okay, so with--
- Because being happy is
gonna be way more cool
than being a millionaire at 31.
- 100%, I 100% agree.
I saw that post on Instagram
the other day, 100%.
- Bro, putting a timeframe
on it is making you unhappy.
- So, have the goals
regardless of how long
it takes to get there.
- When I buy the New York Jets,
I'm gonna sit in that office
room when I sign those papers,
or whatever, fuck the virtual room,
whatever the fuck it is.
And I swear to fucking god,
even though I know the second
I announce it 48 hours later,
24 hours later, an hour later,
the world's gonna rejoice,
there's gonna be a part of me that dies.
- Because you don't have
to chase anymore.
- Process.
That's right.
- The process.
- It's the grind, the dirt.
- It's right, the chase.
You know what I mean?
- I do, I do.
- Make the timeframe forever,
and you'll slow down, you'll
do much better behavior,
it will make you more honorable man too,
because you're not going to fucking try
to quickly get to something
and when you want to get
to something quickly,
your behavior gets bad.
- I agree.
- When somebody wants
something fast, they start
going into darker places.
It's crazy how good my behavior
has become out of patience.
- Okay, okay.
I love that, that's mind blowing.
That's fantastic.
- I really appreciate it.
- Gary, I cannot say
how much I appreciate you.
That's fantastic, Gary.
- Happy to do it.
Good luck, bro.
Take care.
- Thank you, goodbye.
- Team GaryVee, let's chop that up.
I want that on IGTV tomorrow,
maybe even for 7:30 tonight,
that's fucking fire.
There's something really there.
I wasn't reading, Dustin
how were the comments?
That was like a moment, right?
Like do people fucking get it.
- Yeah, people love that moment.
- That's fucking real shit.
I think we helped a lot of people.
- Sure.
- By the way, even going
meta, "Tea with GaryVee"
is resonating with people
because I have more time.
People hate me when I
do podcast interviews
because I have 40 minutes,
I got to get them out,
there's another person, I'm interrupting,
interrupting, interrupting.
"Ask GaryVee" usually is an hour.
They call in, I know I want
to get one or two more.
But this two hours has given
me a little bit of a pacing
that's just an inch slower,
lets me be really sharp,
allows people to finish their
thoughts a little bit better.
Tight.
Let's keep it going.
Hey, how are you?
I can't hear, can't hear you.
- No, we still can't hear you.
I'll keep you on hold on, but we'll...
- Get her fixed up.
- Yep.
- Gary, what's up my brother?
- What's good, Hayden?
How are you Hayden?
- Hey, thank you so much for having me on.
I'm so happy.
I'm getting emotional.
You've helped me so much.
- Thank you, brother.
Where are you from?
- Arizona.
- Very nice, man.
How have I helped you?
- Sorry, dude.
- It's alright, dude.
It's super alright, I
appreciate it so much,
you don't even know how warm
my body feels right now.
Thank you for that.
- So, my question is me and my
dad have a flooring company.
- What kind of company, brother?
- Flooring. So carpet, tile, wood.
- Yep, understood.
- Jeez, I'm so embarrassed about it.
- Don't be embarrassed, bro.
Crying is a strength.
- So, we started three years ago.
My dad's been doing it forever.
So that's part of the reason why I relate,
'cause you worked with your dad,
you guys, you did what you did, anyways.
We've been scaling, we've been growing.
Last year we did a million and a half
in revenue and so
we're happy about that.
- That's great.
- I just graduated college last year.
So anyways, now that I have more time,
because I was working full-time,
I did 60 credit hours last year.
I've started running more ads
and doing more with our
digital marketing stuff.
And it's been blowing up.
Facebook's been killing it for us.
- Facebook's a monster.
Like I've always said.
- Yeah, no, I'm super
deep in your content.
I picked up "Crushing It!"
two or three years ago
and that's what really did it for me.
It was awesome.
And that's crazy, 'cause like you said,
you never know what type of content
is gonna, that's gonna hit deep.
And it was crushing it for me.
- Thank you.
- Anyways, my question is,
we've started to acquire leads
at a very efficient rate.
We've been blowing up on Facebook,
it's been well, there's
no complaint there.
My question is, how do we continue
to scale and handle all of these leads?
- Hiring.
- So me and my dad, obviously he's my dad,
and he kind of, when I say that,
I'm like, "Dad, we just need to hire,
"we just need to trust people,
"we need to give them a
chance, we need to do it."
And he was always like, "Slow down."
- Yep.
This is where it gets emotional.
'Cause you know what's
right for the business.
And you love your pops.
And there's a line in the sand there
and it's super hard.
You're gonna have to fight.
I mean, I'll never be able to explain
how much pushing I did to
get my dad to do things.
My dad's actual natural reaction
to everything on earth is no.
And mine is yes.
And that is a very different framework.
You've got to make your
dad have the conversation.
You can't stop when he says, "Slow down."
Let's roleplay, I'm like,
"But dad, if we hire them,
"if it doesn't work out,
and we can't afford it,
"or if they steal from
us, we can fire them."
- Yeah, but we're not
ready to hire more people.
- But we are, Dad.
I have so many leads coming in
that we're actually now losing money
by not hiring someone, not the reverse.
I know, don't be you, be him.
What will he say to that?
- Yeah, but we don't
have the right analytics
in place to know if we're making money
or we're not making money
off of these salespeople.
- But Dad, what we need to
worry about is the macro,
not the micro, you're over
analyzing the analytics.
We don't need those tools.
If at the end of the year this year,
we do 2.3 instead of 1.5,
and our overhead only went up by 200,000,
that's net positive, Dad.
- Yeah, but let's take it slowly.
I mean, we can hire another salesman
or two in a couple months.
- Dad, I believe in this so much,
that I'm willing not to get paid
for two months to four months
if you let me hire one person
so I can show you.
- Easy, that's easy enough.
(laughs)
- Good, Hayden, so we figured it out.
- So let me work free, Dad.
- So ready, so ready, let's do this.
Go there with him.
Let's see what he does with that.
And if he actually calls
your bluff, good news.
- We've actually hired four salesmen
since the beginning of the year.
- That's huge.
- Yeah, that's what helped
us really, really handle
all these leads.
And we've had a really,
really good quarter so far.
- So it does sound like
dad is supporting offense?
- He is, but it's a hybrid
offense and defense.
'Cause I'm super aggressive
and I'm ambitious.
And I like to work hard
and we both like to go after it,
but he's more defensive
and sometimes he's like,
"Hold on, hold on."
- That's because he's
been through, oh, wait,
that's because it's been
through a whole one.
That's 'cause he's been through some shit.
Actually, I'm really happy
Covid's happening for you
because you can see
what he's talking about.
Now, yep, it looks like you
haven't been affected yet.
Is what I heard from you.
Look, listen.
Family businesses is a give and take.
You've changed the script
up on me a little bit
in a good way with your pop.
How many salespeople did
you have before January?
- We had, like, one or two
and they're kind of rotating
in and out, but because--
- And now you have four full-time?
- Yeah.
- I give pops a lot of credit,
that's a lot of offense.
And so maybe you want it to be seven.
Like, I don't know, if I ever got,
until it really got going,
Those first 3, 4, 5, 6
years, I didn't ever have
100% of what I wanted, ever.
You know, I also was ambitious
and hungry and all that.
I think there is a
responsibility of the child
to have respect for the person
that started it from zero,
which then comes in the
form of getting 40 to 80%
of what you want.
You know, if you want nine, say,
"I'm pretty okay with the four."
You know? What you can
do in that scenario is,
look, there's so many ways to do this.
In that scenario, what you
can do is refine your skills
and your lead gen.
Because Facebook's so
good, people don't realize,
how many different pieces of creative
do you guys have?
- So, I mean, I'm posting at least one
to three times a day.
- And that's organic?
On the fan page, where you're doing ads?
- Yeah and so what I do
is then I take my ads,
'cause I take pictures of jobs that we do
with our guys working and installing,
and then I put those on our Facebook page
and our other social media platforms.
And then I take those posts,
and I create them with ads in mind,
and then I start running
ads against those.
- How many how much creative
do you think you're running
in the Arizona area?
How many different Facebook posts
do you think you have?
- Of ads?
- Yeah, like different pictures.
Because you can have the same picture
going to four different segmentations,
like we're getting into
the nitty gritty now,
like how many different pictures?
- So, I do like four at a time
and I do campaign budget optimization.
And it just goes off,
it goes crazy.
- It runs.
How much video ads are you running?
- Zero, 'cause I don't know what type
of video content to create.
- You didn't know what pictures
to create at first either.
- Come on, man (laughs).
- I'm right, I'm right though!
- Yeah, okay, video content
for a flooring company.
Go, what do you do?
- Good news.
Your fucking pictures aren't
that compelling either.
Whatever the fuck you're
putting in the photo
is fucking just as good in the video
and I can get Hank's
personality out of it.
When you're like "Hank" and he turns over
and I see his dimple and it humanizes him
more than a fucking still photo.
- Yeah, okay.
- Don't pops me!
You're doing to me what
pops does to you now!
- Hey, hey, I'm used to it.
Okay, last thing, ecommerce--
- On some serious shit though,
to your point, I promise you
that 10s of thousands of people
that are watching right now
when you said flooring
photos are like "blah",
but that's 'cause they don't need a floor.
To the point, that photo is to
somebody who needed a floor.
I promise you that video,
if you're holding your fucking phone
and you're like, "Hank, what
are you doing right now?
Well, the sealer doesn't fucking
need to go with the fuck."
And all of a sudden like, oh shit,
you know, like, that shit would work.
Because guess what
happens when you innovate?
Okay, pops, you gave me four.
I'm gonna fucking, this
is what I did by the way,
I'm giving you advice I lived.
Pops, gave me a little room,
I did some ads.
It fucking worked.
Pops didn't want to go to next level,
I'm like, okay, I'm gonna
fucking innovate over here
to generate more, so if
you go fucking innovate
with videos and all of a
sudden your fucking lead's
eight X, and you're like
pops, we had 80 leads before
and you let me have four salesman,
now I have 600 fucking 40 leads, Dad,
what the fuck do you want to do?
- Let's take them, just
you and I, Hayden (laughs).
- Hayden, listen to me,
your pops hired four people,
that would not be his answer.
What you need to do is stop
worrying about his defense
and you need to take your offense
to fucking legendary status.
- Word.
- Word is right.
- One last thing, ecommerce.
How would you approach
ecommerce with flooring?
- I don't know the
flooring sector super well,
is there a lot of ecommerce work being,
like does Home Depot or Lowe's or Amazon
or other people? Yeah?
- Home Depot does.
- I would definitely,
definitely, definitely learn
how to build a Shopify
store if I were you.
- Easy.
- Beautiful.
I would fucking build a Shopify store
and fucking start selling shit
and start running ads
and fucking selling shit.
I fucking beat Wine.com back in the day.
The first one, it was called Wine Shopper.
It's on its fourth
iteration now and this team
has done a good job with it,
but fucking not better than WineText.com.
By the way, Hayden, you drink wine?
- I do not.
- Does pops?
- We do not.
- Alright, respect.
(laughs)
Nonetheless, I would
create a Shopify store.
And I would literally build it up
and I would run Facebook
ads and it will work.
What I love is localization.
Facebook is insane for localization
- Crazy.
- Especially for an older
demo that has the income
to do things like flooring.
- Well and like to your point, Gary,
people are always like,
"No, Facebook won't work for my business."
Whenever I tell people, "Flooring?
"Really, you do flooring on Facebook."
Yeah, it's insane.
- It's called humans are on Facebook,
especially if they're over 40.
And if they're over 40,
oftentimes they have
things they buy and need.
Oh, by the way, the majority
of things that are sold
in this country, and
fucking Facebook dominates.
And it's not as cool as TikTok.
I'm not trying to be cool out here,
I'm trying to build businesses.
- Yeah. That's it. Well, thanks, Gary--
- Shopify, you're welcome, brother, videos
on Facebook, Shopify,
keep putting pressure.
I love your ambition.
I also love pops for delivering
the four salespeople, I do.
- Yeah, no, he's awesome.
You two are my biggest
heroes, so (laughs).
- Thank you brother, I wish you well.
- Have a great day.
- Take care.
You too, Hayden.
(sighs) Tea Time.
I don't know what else is
going on the fucking Internet.
I know at Late Night, oh,
by the way, Late Night,
tonight, 8 p.m., Carmelo Anthony's
"what's in my glass?" session.
I know he's been drinking
wine with some homies,
I'm joining, so when I go
live I'm sure you'll see that.
So, 8 p.m., set your
fucking alerts right now,
8 p.m. on Instagram tonight.
I will be with Melo, drinking
some vino, shooting that shit.
So, I don't know what the
fuck's going on on the Internet
right now, but if people
are not watching this,
if you do not screenshoot
this and share it,
if you do not take this URL
and share it in your Facebook
groups, your email newsletter,
your social media, you are
holding out on your friends.
There's fucking dimes
being dropped out here.
Fuck.
Let's keep it going.
What's good?
- Hi Gary, how you doing?
- Good man, what's your name?
- My name's Sean.
- Sean.
I love the Michigan State fucking--
- Thank you.
- It's fresh.
What's going on, Sean?
- So about a 2013 I created
@RealGoodRhymes Twitter account.
And I just post rhymes.
And I built my social
numbers up pretty good.
Recently, I bought a laser engraver.
I make these little lased wood engraved--
- Really nice.
- Thank you, yeah, it's
a Glowforge machine.
It's a really cool machine.
So, to make content, I
have been giving these out
for free to my followers.
And I'm trying to figure out
when I should be asking
for money for these.
- Now.
- Now? Okay.
- Yeah, I mean, my answer is now,
only sensing your energy that you might be
fearing going in for the ask.
- I've been jabbing a lot
and I just have not put a hook yet.
- You know, it's funny when I wrote
"Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook", I
thought that I was writing it
for people that were spamming
and selling the whole time
and I wanted to teach them,
the jabbing, the romancing,
the bringing value.
What ended up happening,
Sean, is that the feedback
I got was from a lot of people
that are sweet and awesome
like you who actually were
struggling with the ask.
- Yeah.
- Let me say this, Sean.
Do not fear the rejection
of somebody saying no.
Do not fear that you're being
a bad person for asking.
You're asking, you're not demanding.
You're not manipulating,
you're not tricking.
I feel no problem asking
for everybody to sign up
for WineText.com right now.
No, no hesitation.
I feel really good right now.
Look at that, boom.
- (laughs) I love it.
But here's why.
Sean, do you believe,
do you believe, whoa!
Dustin, I want fucking, I
want people to hear this!
Do you believe in what you're selling?
- I do.
- Well, listen--
- I'm early on in the process though.
- That's okay.
- I'm just getting good with the machine,
so I don't want to put out a bad product.
- Here's the good news.
When you sell one, if Mrs Thompson
fucking hits you back and says,
"This is a piece of shit",
you're like, "Mrs Thompson,
I'm devastated, send it back.
"I'll refund you or keep
it and I'll refund you."
You're in control of when
there's disappointment.
- Right, that's true.
- When you sell you have
to believe in what you sell
and you have to be in
control of disappointment.
- Okay.
- Why have I been going completely ham on
on this Wine Text thing?
I'll tell you why.
'Cause today, we're
selling a $65 Cabernet,
that is fucking rated 95 points
by one of the hardest
wine critics in the world.
- That's what's up.
- It's fucking crazy good.
And it's $29 in change
when everybody's selling it for 65.
I fucking believe in it the most.
And like the texting thing is really cool.
You should check it out.
But nonetheless.
Dream, I know you can't sign
up in Utah for Wine Text,
but you should buy Empathy then.
Anyway.
- I had a question about Wine Text, too.
I'm in Michigan.
- Can't do it, I know.
- Oh really?
- Sean, there's state-by-state laws,
and there's certain states
that don't let retailers ship
but they'll let wineries ship.
So, Michigan, Illinois, Texas, Utah,
I can't ship, I can't do Wine Text,
but I can do Empathy.
- I can do Empathy? Okay.
- But Sean, listen to me.
Believe in what you sell.
And remember, you're in control
of if there's a problem.
That should eliminate all of your fears.
When you remember that you're just asking,
and don't be disappointed if nobody buys
because you can't have
expectations of customers.
We have to deliver for them,
they don't have to deliver for us.
- Okay, yeah, so I post rhymes
and I get all all sorts of shares,
and then as soon as I
post one of these things
it's zero engagement, which is--
- Well, that's because that
world was built on rhymes.
What you need to do, do
you have a couple dollars
to potentially run ads?
- I run ads against my rhymes
but not against my product, yeah.
- You feel safe in the rhymes world.
- Yes, I do.
- Yeah, you feel safe.
You feel safe and good there.
We need to get you to feel
safe and good on the woodwork.
- Okay, awesome.
- Alright? Good luck, brother.
- Thanks, you too.
- Take care.
Bye, bye.
Man, this is good.
The Wine Text, thank you, Seb.
Yeah, the Wine Text thing has been nuts.
Please, please, please
sign up for Wine Text.
Right now, like, actually, I'm taking a,
because it's super fast.
Right, what am I doing here? Hold on.
I'm taking literally a 60 second break to,
actually, I have an idea.
Yeah, I'm taking a 60 second break.
Just a moment of silence
to let everybody right now
go to their phone and
sign up for Wine Text.
If they are 21, if they live
in a state that we can ship,
not like Wine Sold Out, not Last Bottle,
not Wine.com, not some club
that you got from Facebook,
like no other platform
is better than Wine Text,
so I'm just gonna wait.
If you've signed up for Wine Text
during this 60 second moment of silence,
please leave a comment that you did,
I just want to see.
It's gonna be hard for me.
Yes, Dustin, please go on
during this moment of silence
and talk.
Thank you, Greg Mullard.
And congratulations on being
sober for all that time.
Thank you, Mind. Thank you for signing up.
Books and Boarding Passes,
Empathy can ship to Arkansas.
Luke Hayden, don't worry,
two more years for you.
What, are you like running a bath? Dustin?
- You hear that?
- I can hear everything.
- It's my cat's water
fountain thing (laughs).
It's so far away I didn't think you
could hear it from here (laughs).
- Okay, fuck that, it's hard.
(laughs)
Alright, let's keep going.
Hi!
Oh, no, it's not working yet.
Let's not take you off yet.
Let's try to figure it out
while we're on together.
Shipping to New York's a
day, a day or two, Beanie.
- Ah!
- Hi!
- Hey, Gary.
Greetings from New Jersey.
- What part?
- I live in Denville,
but I grew up in North Brunswick.
- I love it, Christina,
North Brunswick's super
close to Edison, I love that.
- Yes, yeah, well actually, I'm a lawyer,
I have a law firm in Edison.
- I love that.
- Yeah, so--
- That's awesome.
- That's part of my question (laughs).
- Go ahead.
- Okay, so I'm 45, I co-own a law firm.
Doing divorce law.
- Congrats.
- I absolutely hate it,
I'm totally miserable.
It was what I wanted to do at some point,
but it's not anymore.
And I hear you talk a
lot to the 20 year olds
about "don't care what your parents think,
"do what you want to do, be
happy, don't chase the dollar."
And I think that's great.
I love that message.
But I feel like I'm in
such a different place
that I don't know if it's applicable to me
and I feel totally trapped.
I don't know what to do to get out
of the situation that I'm in.
- You're trapped by the
cost of your lifestyle.
- Yes, yes.
- No shit.
- So, let's talk.
- I need at least $10,000 a month gross
just to pay my bills.
That's not even
- I understand.
- having any fun.
That's because your lifestyle was built
around a career that you hate.
- Yeah.
- Well, good news!
- So, how do I fix that?
What do I do?
- The secret sauce is called humility.
- So downsize--
- I mean, yeah.
- Well, I'm perfectly willing to downsize.
I mean, I really want to go
into broadcast journalism.
I'm trying to figure out how to do that,
I have no shame--
- I have thoughts on that.
- Being a 45 year old intern (laughs).
- I fucking love everything about this.
Let's talk about downsizing, how real?
- I have an Excel
spreadsheet with my budget
and I have whittled down everything
that I could possibly take out.
You know, I do help my
family a little bit.
Not a lot, but a little.
- I respect that.
- You know, not want to
take that away from them.
But I have life insurance.
I have disability insurance.
I have a BMW that is too expensive,
that, I know, that I'm stuck
with for another 14 months.
- Is it leased?
- Yeah, it's leased.
- I mean, there might, I
mean, I'm not educated enough,
but there might be some way
to bring it back to them
and do something with,
and 14 months is not the worst either.
So, let's take a step back.
Are you willing to sell your home?
- I rent, so, no, rent in
New Jersey isn't cheap.
- Fair enough, fair enough.
Look, I think that, look.
So, a couple things, the
other thing you can do,
because a lot of people
can't even downsize,
because, you know, they can't.
So, let's play a different game.
What you can do is use, and this is,
the first book I wrote, "Crush It!",
was during 2008, during this time.
And my big theory then was like,
look, you've got to pay your bills,
and you've got to maintain your lifestyle,
whatever that may be, whether
it's 1000 bucks a month,
or 10,000 bucks a month.
So, why don't you really focus
on 7 p.m. to two in the morning, right?
And when I hear about
broadcast journalism,
if I'm you, I start a
Facebook Live show immediately
at night, literally "Tea With GaryVee",
but like "Wine With Christina",
and like, literally start
fucking interviewing people,
like, literally, spend seven
or eight to 10 booking people,
and for the next day,
like doing it every other day,
one night is booking people,
the next day's interviewing them,
and put your abilities on film.
Like, literally give people the look,
like one of the ways you can do this.
There's two ways to do it.
You downsize so much that you can
actually sell your
partnership to your partner,
different lawyer, take those dollars,
have a nest egg and go
for a year or two trying
to go into journalism.
Or, you can maintain your
lifestyle-ish at 14 months.
Definitely fuck everyone's
opinions on your BMW,
get something else, lower
that, lower everything,
and then work at night
to build your new world,
which will then lead to
speaking, or books, or a job.
And so you kind of do the flip,
you're like fixing the
plane while you're on it.
And then you can make the switchover,
because now instead of
10,000 being an issue,
you're gonna get a $6,000 offer.
You cut your expenses by 4000.
And you see where I'm going,
you kind of flip there.
But you need to create content
and put yourself out there
to create the opportunity
and that has to happen
at night, late night.
- Yeah, I have a podcast
but I have been thinking
about making it a Facebook
Live interview series.
- Facebook Live.
- But I like your idea
of having a regular show.
- You have to have a show.
Show the world what you are
and the Internet now lets that happen.
I mean, I've turned down
fucking 500 TV show offers.
- That's awesome.
- And it happened because I put myself
in that position in 2006
with a wine show, you know?
And then later business content.
Like, you can do that too.
You may not get 500, but
good news, you only need one.
- Yeah, I do.
- Listen to me.
What's probably happening
is you have an intense job,
you come home, probably late,
you're probably working
at home sometimes as well,
and watch fucking watching
things, have a glass of wine,
these, have a glass of wine,
do some shit, right?
What you need to do is
realize you're unhappy.
And so you have to turn
those hours at night
into becoming the next
version of yourself.
- Well, I have a partner too,
and I think I feel a little
guilty sometimes just, I don't know,
abandoning him or leaving him
because he's not happy either.
- That's very sweet.
That's very sweet.
So encourage him too, let
him watch this fucking video,
like, encourage him to.
- Yeah.
Thank you.
- I mean, there's tons
of bigger law firms that
would love to swoop up
your client list or your brand.
- Yeah, I mean, I'd
love to be in a position
to sell the firm.
I don't, at this point,
I don't need to be rich.
I think when you get miserable it's--
- Happy (laughs).
- It doesn't matter how
much money you make.
I don't need to drive
around in the BMW if I'm--
- Nobody gives a fuck.
- No!
- People are so confused.
As if you get like one
good day from your buddies.
This is for the youngsters out there,
or the people that are about to buy,
I mean, when you talk
about nobody giving a fuck
about a fancy car,
if you have a fancy car, what
do you think is happening?
Somebody envies you for
a day? Who gives a shit?
- Yeah, it's true.
- Nobody gives a fuck.
And that goes to clothes.
And that goes to your
photo on you on a boat,
like, I don't know if people are seeing it
but what's happening
on Instagram right now
It's just high school.
That's just high school.
You know, freshman and sophomore year
you think the prettiest
girl and the coolest guy
are fucking awesome.
By the time you're in the
last half of senior year,
you think they're fucking douchebags!
- Well, it looks like flexing too,
it doesn't look like authenticity.
- Yeah, listen, some people really love
the way a BMW drives
and they can afford it
and fucking amazing.
Or always their whole
life they dreamed about
having a Jaguar and they understand shit.
Amazing.
But so many people buy it
'cause they think they're supposed to.
Or they subconsciously
need that affirmation.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm more mindful
now of buying things that--
- Of course, listen, I get it Christina,
please, know this is not
judgment, I'm with you.
27 year old you versus 44 you, I get it.
Everyone goes through the same things.
The beauty is, nobody on
TV or magazine or radio
was talking about this shit back then.
Thank God we have the Internet now
that you, we're kids, we're
in the same age group,
we're still kids.
You're gonna live for 50 more years,
you want to be miserable for
another 30 professional years?
No way.
So if you're in a spot where you feel
kind of slightly, look,
renting in New Jersey
in Denville is different
than renting in New Jersey and Edison,
or renting in New Jersey
in fucking Springfield,
like you're in control of your humility.
If that hurts too much,
which I have a lot of empathy for,
then you need to really
focus on your nights
and start building your new future.
But those are the only two
fucking prescriptions that work.
- I'm fine with that.
I call it the misery threshold.
Once you get to your misery threshold,
you don't even care,
you'll do anything.
- It's facts.
It's fucking facts.
You know, it's so funny,
Philadelphia fan said "move to PA".
It's really been interesting.
I grew up, my high school years,
I grew up like childhood years in Edison,
but my high school years in
Hunterdon County, New Jersey,
which is like exit like
12, 15 on 78 out west,
and I'm seeing a lot of people
in the Springfield, Edison,
Bergen County area start
to really consider like,
right over the bridge by Phillipsburg,
and just, there's so many
options to your point
when you're fucking unhappy.
- Yeah, the BMW isn't
important after a while.
- Nobody gives a fuck.
- No, but there's
a lot of people my age,
- No, but there's a lot of people my age,
they're just over saddled with a mortgage.
I don't even have that, I'm
lucky I don't have kids,
because I don't have
those responsibilities.
But I hear so many people say,
"Well, what am I supposed,
what am I gonna do now?
"I've got a family to support
"and a wife that stays at home."
- Nobody has the humility to move.
Nobody has the courage to
go and say to their wife,
"We're moving."
What people don't realize
is this is why so many
people are on opioids
and alcohol and just, like, they're sad.
Then they're spending more
money to go to therapy,
it's tough man.
This is why have we have to redefine,
listen, it is our responsibility,
we grew up in a Gen X world
where success mattered, things mattered,
and it's our responsibility
to educate these kids
and ourselves that we
need to shed this shit.
And we need to make happiness
to ROI, not fucking money.
- Yeah, it's really true.
- So, what would you recommend that I do
once I get the Facebook
Live interview thing going,
the show, the daily show?
- DM everybody you can.
- I don't want to just wait
for people to see it.
What do I do to get it in
front of the right people?
- Instead of spamming people
and say "watch my show",
what you want to do is
reach out to people on DM
like crazy on Instagram DM.
The biggest names, Katie
Couric or fucking Gayle King,
or fucking LeBron, literally
asking, being relentless
to ask, "Do you want to be on my show?"
And then the names that you land,
I'd rather you land and spam
VIPs that are on the show
that then bring awareness to your show
than hitting up executives and saying,
"Look how good I am at this."
I promise you, if you do the show,
agents and networks and talent firms
and managers will start reaching out.
I mean, I just go back to my time.
I was good at it and then
2006, CAA, William Morris,
Endeavor, managers, networks,
I was getting bombarded.
When you're good, you're good.
And sometimes it takes time to be good.
Sometimes you're born with it,
but you have a very good presence,
like I can feel that already, I mean that.
- Thank you, thank you,
I appreciate that.
- It's a Jersey girl thing.
- Yes (laughs), people on
the West Coast love that!
- Spend time on getting the guests
that will work out what you want.
It's kind of like girl, boy dynamics.
If you can create a world
where it's coming to you,
versus you're chasing it,
you'll always have the leverage.
- Awesome, awesome, so will
you be on my show? (laughs)
- I will be on your show
if you get 15 other guests.
Show me that you're in.
And then you email me and
say, "Gary, you're number 16."
It's Gary@VaynerMedia.
You show me the 15 guests,
and it can't be your fucking aunt.
I need to see real shit.
- (laughs) Alright, alright.
- Alright, you got it.
Take care.
- Thank you!
- You got it, bye, bye.
Ready, New Jersey?
By the way, anybody in New Jersey
who's not part of Wine Text,
qho's not part of Wine Text,
if you're buying from fucking Bottle King,
or Total Wine, or some bullshit,
anybody in New Jersey who has
not signed up for Wine Text?
I'm fucking...
Let's keep it going.
Hello.
- Oh, my gosh. Oh!
- What's good?
- Okay, okay, hi!
- Hi, what's your name?
- Shamil, Shamil.
- You can take this off, Dustin. Comments.
- As you see here, I play here,
I'm sorry, it's like a delay.
My apologies.
- I see, no worries,
you're good.
- Okay, cool.
So, just to give you a little
bit of backstory about me,
I grew up in a super small town,
Sanford, North Carolina.
Shout out to Bojangles.
And I actually moved here to Las Vegas
with my grandparents when
I was eight years old.
My grandfather owned his
own business in New York.
Sorry, I'm a little bit nervous.
He owned his own business in New York,
and he was shining shoes.
Then he came here to Las
Vegas a little bit later
with us and owned his own business
at the Wynn Encore shining shoes as well.
So, with that,
entrepreneurship has just been
kind of in my blood,
I wanted to sell hair weave
when I was in college,
I wanted to sell snacks at
school when I was in high school.
So, essentially I started
my own cosmetic line
called The Unicorn Locker Cosmetics,
and our business, or my business,
is built upon empowering
women with knowledge
and understanding that you
can be anybody you want to be,
it doesn't matter where you come from,
it doesn't matter how you grew up,
the life that you lived, who
raised you, none of that.
I want to mentor young girls,
we offer cosmetics between
eye products, lip products,
skin products and things like that.
So, essentially, I've been
listening to you for years now
and I was able to earn
35,000 followers on TikTok.
- Wow.
- And it means a lot to me
because those little girls
leave so many comments
with so much positivity.
And it lets me know that
there are not people,
who, I don't think anybody's,
this is kind of like a side note,
I don't think anybody's
born racist or hateful,
'cause there's so many people--
- It's taught behavior,
- Dude!
- It's taught, it's taught.
- They're so kind and
they're like eight years old.
So I'm like, there's no
way that you you grew up
and then, you became this horrible person.
So, essentially, what
I'm trying to do is learn
how to funnel people from
my TikTok to my Instagram,
and then to my website for sales.
So, I also offer--
- So, you have the URL to your website
in your Instagram obviously, right?
- Yes.
- How much content on TikTok
are you putting to give awareness
that you're on Instagram?
- Actually not very much.
I guess I misunderstood--
- Well, that's a problem.
- Yeah, I misunderstood,
I guess I thought that they
would not show the content
if I mentioned a different
platform or something like that.
- Nope.
- Okay, okay.
And then I had also seen
your previous comments
to a couple other people
last week about posting maybe
once or twice a day, letting people know,
"Hey, I want to give you
some incentives to head over
"to my Instagram, spend
some time with you,
"if you follow me."
- Or you can be creative
where you start a skit or a
piece of content on TikTok
and then you say right at the end,
"Oh, you want to see the end of this?
"Go to my Instagram now."
And boom,
then you post on Instagram.
- Ooh!
- So you can do a little bit that play.
- Okay.
- You see where I'm going?
- Okay, okay.
- You can make a post on TikTok,
"Hey TikTok, I love all of you family,
"I'm doing an Instagram
Live tonight at 7 p.m.
"Leave a comment if you're in, I'll reply.
"I'll see tonight at 7 p.m.
"My Instagram's the same
as it is here on TikTok."
You see where I'm going?
- Yes, okay, okay.
Perfect, perfect.
- Got it?
- So, with that I also
use the content structure
that you posted.
It's as far as repurposing content.
I also use the Join Team
GaryVee blog that you posted
about how we would make content for you
and I try to use that for me.
And I find that it really helps.
However, my time management
gets a little bit skewed
because I make everything
myself, SEO, website,
products, graphics, videos,
pictures, everything.
So how do I use that
structure to my advantage
when I have all these
other things that I'm doing
and I don't have anybody.
- By not judging yourself.
I didn't have anybody either for 10 years.
- Yeah.
- Patience.
- Okay, okay, cool, cool.
- It's super important, real quick,
everybody's watching.
I did all my own, everyone's like,
"You've got a team, you've
got doo-ra, blah, Dustin."
Like, I fucking did it for 10 years.
Solo.
- True.
- Me.
- By myself.
- Okay, cool, cool.
- You know, everybody sees the this, now.
They didn't see 2004,
they didn't see 2001,
they didn't see 2006,
they didn't see 2009.
You can go on YouTube
and find videos of me
that has fucking 49 views.
You can go on Twitter and
find posts that got one like.
- Right
- Type, everybody's right now,
go type in "Gary Vee 2008"
on Twitter search right now.
You'll see posts that have
four likes, zero likes.
How do you time manage?
By not judging yourself.
- And not feeling bad if you don't do it,
- People spend more time feeling bad
and dwelling and judging themselves
about their time management,
which just fucks up their time management.
- Right, right, and you sit there
and you start spending time
- People spend an hour
and a half. Yeah, if you
gave every minute back,
that you beat yourself up,
that you didn't do it well enough,
or I'm scatterbrain, or I fucking this,
or it's always gonna be like this,
or I'll never, if you
fucking spent every second
that you spend on dwelling
and beating yourself up on
on actually doing shit,
you wouldn't be fucking
stressing about time management.
- Right, man, okay, big
facts. Okay, cool, cool.
So I also have a lot of
people who look at my posts,
I can see my engagement,
see the video views
and things like that on Instagram,
however, they're not
navigating to my site.
So, I'm trying to figure
out, what am I doing wrong?
I like to give them a lot of tips,
post a lot of content, so--
- Once in a while on Instagram,
how often to do post on Instagram?
- Ah, probably maybe two
to three times a day.
- Great.
One of those, or go to four times a day,
- Okay.
- And straight up do a
hardcore right hook and be like,
"Yo, go to my website."
- Okay.
- Obviously, way more creative than that.
- Right?
- You know what I mean?
But like, "Yo, I'm doing
this on my website."
Or put up something on your website.
Look what I did. I put out a deck.
That cost me a lot of money and time
that deck that you're using.
I didn't sell it.
There's all sorts of fuckers trying
to sell shit for $5,000 or 3000,
you know what I mean?
- Right.
- Why don't you put out
a nice piece of content?
Why don't you put out a
self-esteem for 12 year olds deck
on your website, so that when
you say go to my website,
you feel proud that there's something
they're gonna get some value about.
- I agree, I agree, so I also have a blog
that I just recently began as well.
And I'll be reaching out
to different makeup artists
and Facebook groups to ask--
- Real quick, I apologize,
Duskyco, yes, four times a day.
I post four times a day on Instagram.
Four times a day.
Keep going.
- No problem, so I actually
lost my train of thought, but--
- I apologize for interrupting.
- No, it happens to me a lot.
- But listen, oh, you said
you just started blogging.
- Yes, I just started blogging.
And I'm also going to be
reaching out to makeup artists
and Facebook groups,
asking them for their tips.
So that way they can be
featured inside of the blog,
bringing awareness to the
blog, and things like that.
So, I do feel a little bit
better when people come
to the site, they actually
have something to look at.
So with that, as far
as my actual site SEO,
how important is SEO, if you're
working on building a brand.
I spend a lot of time creating content.
And I also try to leverage my
time with SEO on my website,
so I can actually show up on Google.
So, how important is that for a startup?
- It's important, but I think
that it's a very complex,
very mature business,
and that a lot of people,
a lot of small people,
can't win that SEO game
as much as they think,
where they can win the TikTok
game like you did, right?
So, it's important, but me personally,
I'm a believer at this moment
that most small players
need to focus on social
content, raise their funds up
and potentially hire outside
SEO, 'cause it's so mature.
- Right, okay.
Okay, cool.
- I like that you know
what it is, so when you do
pay somebody on the outside,
you don't get caught.
- Manning.
- 'Cause, you know.
- Yeah, yeah, and I also took
a Google Analytics course,
I got Google Analytics certified.
- Good for you.
- I've been looking
at my stats to be able to
determine exactly what's going on.
So, basically, I think
that's pretty much all
that I needed.
- Good.
- Oh, one more thing,
though. One more thing.
I know Megan Thee Stallion is your pal.
Can you plug me so I can
send her some glitter?
- (laughs) Send me an email.
- That's all I wanna do,
is give her some makeup for free.
- Let me see what I can do.
Take care.
- Thank you so much.
- Talk to you soon.
- Bye!
- Bye, bye.
Go back to that guy who
said I was a piece of shit.
It's a great point.
I really appreciate him.
- I gotta find it.
- No worries. Raspberries are underrated.
But I can just speak to it.
- Yeah.
- It is really interesting
that aggressiveness and
high energy confuses people
at first, so if you're
on YouTube or Twitter
right now watching and at first
when you first saw me, you're like,
"Fuck this guy, bullshit, fuck this."
Just reply now "me".
I just want to see how many. "Me."
Alright, let's keep 'em going.
I eat these berries, I
can do my fucking job.
Chris!
- Oh, shit!
- What's good, bro?
- I feel like I'm 14 again
in the early '90s and I just called my
favorite radio station and
I'm caller number seven.
- I love it, Chris. Where you at?
- Colorado.
- Very nice. It's good to see you.
- Nice, you too, brother.
- What can I answer for you?
(static)
- I'm a homesteader.
You know, me and my wife
left our corporate lives
and sold all the shit we didn't need
and moved out to the middle of nowhere.
Just trying to document
the journey on YouTube
and how do you be yourself,
or how do I be my nerdy ass self,
in front of the camera?
'Cause when I'm solo
with it, I just clam up.
- I understand.
So, Chris, I think it comes
down to taking a big step back
and really, really, really
thinking about the following.
Why in the world,
especially when you have such
a fucking epic red beard,
why in the world would
you ever, ever, ever
let somebody's anonymous opinion
stop you from telling you your truth?
Literally, right before
you came on right now,
and I think you probably heard it,
I asked a question of
how many of you when you
first saw me thought I was bullshit,
fuck this guy.
I just, while you were talking,
and I was admiring your background.
I saw an ungodly amount of people say me.
You can imagine, as a human,
that doesn't feel great.
It's just that I've conditioned myself,
at this point, to be empathetic
to other people's opinions,
'cause they don't know me.
Same with you, brother.
You can be nerdy because it doesn't matter
if people think you're nerdy,
or boring, or not boring.
You just got to keep persevering.
You're gonna find your crew.
- Right, right.
- A lot of people asking--
- I don't even know if it's so much that
'cause, I mean, there's probably what,
10,000 people watching this right now,
and I can talk to you and
conjunct a coherent sentence.
But when I'm solo with the camera,
like, my brain just goes to mush
and I can't organize my thoughts.
- I got an idea.
It's really funny.
- What's that?
- You have a similarity to me.
I actually hate being solo too.
I need action.
Notice I'm bringing Dustin in?
- Yeah, that's kinda how I am,
I do better interacting.
- When I did "Wine Library TV",
I made Caster and Chris Motts,
people used to think I said "ma", Motts.
Those people behind the camera.
I used to interact with them
because I needed the action.
When I did "Ask Gary Vee",
I mean, India and Stunwin and
those characters part of it.
I'm doing "Tea With Gary Vee",
I'm making Dustin a part of it.
So, what you may want to
do is when you make videos,
you may want to go on
Facebook Live, or YouTube Live
and do it live, because you're
getting a little bit of that
human interaction that
you're feeling right now.
Or, or, you might need a virtual co-host.
- How would you do that?
- I mean, we're co-hosts right now.
- Okay, that makes sense.
- Right? You go to StreamYard.com,
that's like a platform,
you hit up your buddies
or somebody you think
could be good at this
and maybe what you need is a co-host.
Some people are way better with co-hosts
than they are solo.
- So, how would I incorporate that in
with like my daily
things that I have to do
when I'm homesteading?
That I want to document?
- When you're homesteading
and documenting,
you don't even need to talk to camera.
Maybe you just document it
and then you do voiceover
with you and that person
after the fact in post-production,
- Okay.
- See what's awesome about this, Chris, is
what has always driven me
is the ability to have ideas
and to always look for yes.
Like, there's nothing you or
anybody else can say that's
gonna stop me.
Or make me say, "Well, we can't."
There's always things to do.
The fact that you can
document what you're doing,
and then do post-production voiceover,
might be the unlock.
- Yeah, that's definitely
one to think about for sure.
- You like that, right?
That's kind of fresh.
- Yeah, that's a good idea.
- You know, I mean, maybe
you feel way more comfortable
watching your day, and even talking
about what was on your mind.
As a matter of fact,
that's a good idea for me
for DailyVee, like the coolest shit
is actually in my mind that you can't see.
What I'm saying out loud--
- Right, right.
- As entertaining and smart as it is,
I promise you it's fucking secondary
to what's going on in here.
- Right, right.
And yeah, I spent a lot of time because,
well, I mean, I have my wife
and my kids and whatnot,
but I do a lot of solo
projects around here.
So, I spend a lot of time internalizing.
You know?
- I love that, I love that.
I think filming that as,
quote unquote boring as it
may seem in what you're doing,
I would argue it isn't.
Especially if you voiceover and be like,
"Yo, I was looking at this fucking plant.
"They're doing this", or
whatever the fuck you're doing.
Right? By the way, what's your channel?
People are bombarding me
for what your channel is.
- It's Barr None Off Grid, with two Rs.
- I love that, Chris, Barr what?
- Barr None Off Grid.
- Dustin, you got that?
'Cause I know we're
gonna put the link here.
Is that it? Right here,
Chris, can you see that?
- What's that?
Oh, yeah. That's it.
- All one word, right? For YouTube?
- Ah, no, it's separated
just like he wrote it.
- Good job, Dustin.
Chris, I wish you luck.
I'm telling you right now,
I really like the idea
of you just filming it
and then taking it into
post-production and talking over it.
- Okay.
You think you can do that,
or are you just yessing me?
- I'm gonna have to put down tracks,
see how that works out then.
- How does that feel in your gut?
Like, "Nah, that's not gonna work, Gary?"
Or, talk to me?
- I don't know.
I think it's probably
better than me being solo
with the camera trying to talk to it.
But it's still just me talking like,
I don't know, I don't know,
I guess maybe I am like you,
(static) I do way better
in an interactive scenario.
- Why don't you try going
live on YouTube or Facebook
for the whole day and
interacting with the phone,
see how that feels?
- Okay, no, yeah. I've never
tried livestream on YouTube,
but I don't really have
a lot of followers.
- Chris--
- I don't know how many people
would watch if I went live.
- Chris, when I went live
on Ustream back in the day,
back in the back, back, back day,
I fucking had like seven,
eight people in there
and they became my family,
and eight became 13 and 13 became 22.
What you can do is before
you go live the first time,
why don't you go to your address book
and text literally everybody
your YouTube channel,
and say, "Listen,
tomorrow's a big day for me,
"I'm gonna go live, and I just
need some people in there.
"And it would mean a
lot to me if you came."
You're gonna have six to
15 friends jump in there.
- Okay.
- Chris, you know what's funny?
Chris, you just went up 100 followers
on your YouTube subscriber
list since we've been talking.
- You kidding me?
That's fucking fantastic (laughs).
- I think it's fucking fantastic, too.
- Wow.
I don't even know what
to say to that right now.
- Well, guess what?
Here's what I have to say to it.
Now you have a base.
Now you have a base of
people that will join
you on your first YouTube Live.
Take advantage of it, my friend.
Use this serendipitous moment
to start the next chapter.
- Right, right.
Just gotta grind and kill it.
- You had 35 followers now you have 142.
- Jesus. That's insane (laughs).
- It's a good day, Barr.
- Hey, appreciate it, brother.
- I appreciate you.
Let's throw up his channel
one more time, Dustin.
Chris, have a great, great day.
- Thanks, Gary. Love you.
- You got it.
I love you back.
Let's spend the last
couple minutes here solo.
Gonna start doing this this way.
Let's recap.
Today's recap. Look,
just doing nice things,
I thank all of you, first and
foremost you as a community,
thank you so, so, so, so, so much
for following Chris's channel.
That means a lot to me.
You can see we made that
wonderful man's day.
There's a lot of patience,
a lot of inside your own head.
If you really think about the themes,
it's so funny back to the thing we did
where it was me, me, me.
I can come across hard and aggressive
and Jersey and cursing
and I can look like a
lot of the spammy people
that are just trying
to get you into funnels
and bullshit, I get it.
But the reality is, the
religion here is patience
and kindness and empathy
and self-esteem and self-awareness
and kindness and empathy.
And I just really
appreciate having this time
with you guys to really
keep pounding that home
and I think more and more every single day
it's becoming more obvious to people
what's really happening here.
A couple things I want to end up with.
One, please, please share the show.
I really think we're
doing something meaningful
and I want more people,
and there's a lot of people
who do think I'm a douchebag,
and maybe them watching two
or three, or new people,
I think we're doing a lot of good here.
And so I also know this format
is probably not sustainable
and will be over somewhere
here in the next 30 or 60 days.
So, if you can take a screenshot
and post it to all your
places, text friends,
start a WhatsApp group,
like if you're a Facebook
group moderator for sure.
Please spread this love, far and wide.
That would mean a lot to me.
And I just appreciate it.
Dustin come in here, let's
chat for a few minutes
as we wrap up the show.
What did you see out there today?
- A lot of good comments.
Not too many bad comments
or anything like that.
That's why I was trying to show them
but couldn't find too many.
A couple of spam stuff--
- Shout out, real quick,
I apologize,
Jonathan Smith, "Tea
Time" starts every morning
at 9 a.m. Eastern, 6
a.m. on the West Coast.
By the way, I guess he's up to 300,
he's at 400 subscribers now.
- Crazy.
- What an incredible love.
What else did you see, Dust?
- Unfortunately, I
wasn't being able to pay
attention 'cause there's
a lot going on here.
- Yep, yep, yep, no worries.
- So a lot of it just went in one ear,
went out the other.
- I respect that.
Are we gonna figure out the
Facebook comments for tomorrow?
- Yeah.
- Cool, we'll have that right.
It was a good show.
There were some really good ones.
Did anything stand out to you,
or were you like so in producer mode
it was hard to even
really follow the content?
- Just the guy that was
like in tears right away.
I was like, "Wow."
- Hayden.
I really like the kid that really got it.
The patience thing, like the framework.
- I forgot which one that was.
- He was the kid that I was like,
"You're putting a time
limit on your ambition."
- A lot of people in
the comments were like
"wow, wow, wow" and stuff
like that when that happened.
- Dust, thanks for all your hard work.
Thank you for hooking
it up with StreamYard.
StreamYard, big shout out.
We're enjoying the platform.
I think you like it, Dust?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Which matters to me.
Okay, cool. You out of here, Dust.
Dust, throw up Wine Text here right now,
I'm gonna spend the last four minutes
guilting people to sign up.
It's just a very simple guilt.
If you buy wine from
anybody else besides me,
I'm struggling with that.
If you don't buy wine,
don't sign up for Wine Text.
I don't need the sign up.
It costs money to send a
text, don't sign up at all
if you're not a wine buyer.
But if you buy wine, it
would mean the world to me
to support my dad.
Okay and now let's finish
up with some shoutouts
on the way out. Gliss Life,
thank you for watching.
Eli Murphy was in the chat
the whole time, big shout out.
The Cherry Picker, I
really appreciate you.
Thank you for being here.
Oh, as a matter of fact,
if you are on YouTube
or Twitter right now,
please reply with what state you live in.
Give me a little shout out.
Also, throw it up, 212-931-5731
if you are looking to get on this show,
as I know a lot of you are,
please text 212-931-5731 your
question put #TeaWithGaryVee
so the team can find it.
I'm probably gonna send
out a blast to everybody
on text to join Team
With GaryVee community.
So you look for that.
We'll tell you how to do that.
Big shout out to Sydney,
Australia for Nico.
Rich Klein in New York, you
better sign up for Wine Text.
Thank you, Bat.
Thank you, Vancouver. Big shout out.
Big shout out to Scott from Indiana.
Big shout out to Vaughn in Utah.
Good to see you, Jenny. Good to see you.
Alright, final part, right
now take a screenshot of this.
Ooh, that would be good
with the Wine Text.
Take a screenshot of this.
Actually, not this, not this, not this.
This how I want to end,
'cause I want to really say thank you.
Back to the Wine Text, Dustin.
If you sign up for Wine
Text, please tweet me,
Gary V-E-E, with your screenshot
of the confirmation sign up.
I've got a little (clicks).
See you. Love you.
We'll see you tomorrow, 9
a.m., "Tea With Gary Vee".
Be nice today.
It's always the right answer.
- Okay, so Team Gary has
made a lot of content
over the years.
But what's your favorite piece
of content that was made?
- That's a great question.
My favorite content by far is--
- I'm considering doing
a VaynerMedia operation
stay-at-home day once a week forever,
'cause I'm pretty sold that
I've gotten more done per day
than sometimes in a month.